j'informe l'assemblée que la présidente
a pris acte du dépôt de deux motions de
censure en application de l'article 49
alé 3 de la Constitution la première
ministre ayant engagé la responsabilité
du Gouvernement sur l'adoption de la
2uxème partie du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2024 lune le 25 octobre 2023 à 18h34 par
Madame Mathilde Panau madame cyielle
châelin monsieur André chassegne et 111
de leurs collègues l'autre le 26 octobre
2023 à 18h par Madame Marine Le Pen et
87 de ses collègues en conséquence
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion et
le vote sur ces motions de
censure la parole est d'abord à monsieur
Adrien Clouet pour le groupe la France
insoumise et pour une durée de 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes
présidente collègu ministre l'Assemblée
nationale vous le savez ne veut pas de
votre budget de la Sécurité sociale ce
budget nous l'avons rejeté en commission
jusque-l le scénario est connu c'est le
même que les 13 précédents mais il y a
une nouveauté c'est que vous n'avez pas
été fichu de trouver une seule personne
dans le pays qui l'approuve en tout cas
pas une en dehors évidemment de vos amis
qui se soignent dans des cliniques privé
pour super riches pas une organisation
qui estime ce budget potable il est
refusé par la totalité des syndicats et
organisations interprofessionnelles il
est refusé par les conseils de la CNAM
et de l'UNCAM par les deux grandes
fédérations hospitalières par celles
d'établissements d'hospitalisation à
domicile par Unic cancer par les
associations d'usagers comme l'UNAF ou
France ass santé mais également c'est
pas suffisant par le monde mutualiste
comme la Mutualité française sans
compter les fédérations de soignants
convergence de tout le monde dans le
pays contre votre budget collègue
quand on réalise une telle union contre
soi et qu'on persiste c'est qu'on
gouverne pour des intérêts inassumables
en l'occurrence celui de grand monopole
privé et de groupes financiers qui le
faire main basse sur l'ensemble de la
sécurité sociale et c'est pour ces
raisons et c'est pour cette complicité
que votre gouvernement doit
tomber d'autant que lorsqu'on s'oppose à
vous vous pratiquer le holdup c'est le
bon mot le holdup puisque vous
dépossédez les assurés de leur argent la
sécurité sociale elle n'est pas à vous
elle est à celles et ceux qui
l'alimentent par le biais des
cotisations fondées sur leur force de
travail un point c'est tout la sécurité
sociale ce n'est pas madame bornne qui
sort de sa berline pour nous faire gober
un budget écrit lui-même sur un coin de
table j'entends les protestations je dis
madame borne évidemment c'est une
formule de style pour inclure tous les
ministres qui sort de sa berline pour
nous faire goberber un budget écrit sur
un coin de table puis puis puis puis
viens forcer le tordre le bras à
l'Assemblée nationale pour obtenir son
adoption non la sécurité sociale ce sont
les travailleuses et travailleurs qui se
réunissent et qui définissent
collectivement les besoins à couvrir
puis fort de cette définition collective
décide quelle part des richesses commune
c'est-à-dire de leur salaire ils
allouent à la prévention des risques de
la vie ces risques de la vie qui peuvent
arriver à toutes et à tous à savoir la
protection des malades des petits des
familles ou encore des retraités et dès
lors que ce sont les salariés associés
qui organise leur protection collective
et bien on a la plus belle assurance qui
existe contre les réformes que vous nous
promettez je pense évidemment à la
réforme des retraites qui a volé 2 ans
de vie à toutes et à tous puisque vous
trahissez ce principe fondamental de la
République sociale qu'est la sécurité
sociale et son autonomie vous devez
partir vous et votre
gouvernement
alors si personne ne vous fait confiance
si la méthode ne suscite aucun
enthousiasme c'est évidemment parce que
vous refusez de sortir le chèque de 10
milliards eur qui serait nécessaire pour
couvrir l'ensemble des besoins et des
risques sociaux ce chèque de 10
milliards d'euros si vous le voulez le
voici il n'y a plus qu'à signer
évidemment j'ai laissé en blanc la
signature pour madame la Première
ministre s'il fallait financer une
multinationale polluante s'il fallait
consentir encore des cadeaux fiscaux aux
grandes entreprise évidemment vous
l'auriez sorti mais dès qu'il s'agit de
permettre aux gens de bien vivre et bien
vous couperz les budgets en témoigne une
série de dispositions de ce texte dont
chacune individuellement justifierait
que le gouvernement tombe les arrêts
maladies sont désormais limités à 3
jours lorsqu'ils sont prescrits en
téléconsultation dit autrement
habitantes ou habitant d'un désert
médical sans médecins traitant seront dé
nués d'arrêt de droit à l'arrêt maladie
idée brillante puisqu'ils se rendront
donc au travail contaminer leurs
collègues lesquels eux-mêmes ne pourront
pas poser d'arrêt et ainsi de suite
quant à celui ou celle qui passerait
entre les gouttes et arriverait à
accéder à un médecin un médecin sans
doute de plus de 70 ans à 21h30 qui le
reçoit au mépris de sa vie de famille et
bien il sera ensuite contrôlé par un
autre médecin qui aura choisi son son
patron désormais seuls les médecins
liignés sur le MDEF contrôleront les
arrêts maladies posées alors si la
situation est très grave et que le
patient laatiente ne peut bouger et bien
il pourra appeler un taxi conventionné
pour être emmené vers un centre de soins
et si votre texte passe on leur répondra
que non le transport sanitaire sera
partagé avec d'autres histoire de se
contaminer entre patients bien
évidemment et de rendre public l'état de
santé des malades à tout leur voisinage
une fois arrivé dans cet hôpital le
patient sera pris en charge par un insue
une organisation dans laquelle il manque
3 milliards et demi d'euros d'après la
Fédération hospitalière de France dont
l'ancien président siège avec vous donc
c'est vous dire le crédit des chiffres
il manque donc 100 millions d'euros par
CHU rien d'étonnant depuis 2021
l'inflation a augmenté de 13 % tandis
que les dotations aux établissements de
santé ne progressaient que de 11 %. ces
deux points d'écart qui représentent 2
milliards d'euros et bien ils sont
cherchés par les soignantes les
soignants l'administration en se serrant
la ceinture dès lors en parvoie de
conséquence le patient arrive dans un
hôpital au soignant mal payé en he sub
gratuite sans lit avec des fenêtres
cassées des machines en panne et une
pénurie de médicament pour être guéri
pénuine médicament pas de souci dans
votre monde il suffit de ne plus
prescrire de cortisone et d'amoxyyine
pour que le problème disparaisse à
savoir la santé des personnes bref vous
soumettez un budget de clochardisation
la santé publique et pour avoir osé le
présenter c'est une raison indépendante
de tout le reste de demander votre
départ les seules mesures dans tout là
qui présente un quelconque intérêt son
copier-collé des oppositions notamment
les amendements de la France insoumise
c'est l'hommage du vis à la vertu on
sait l'apprécier puisque en 2022 on
proposait la gratuité des protections
périodiques ou la vaccination HPV jugé à
l'époque irrecevable et les voici dans
votre texte article 17 et 19 vous savez
trouver des bonnes idées chez les autres
c'est déjà ça à défaut d'en avoir
vous-même mais ce qui bloque c'est
toujours la même chose le refus de
sortir les 10 milliards d'euros pourtant
de l'argent il y en a vous injectez
presque le double dans votre caisse
d'amortissement de la dette sociale
récapitulons puisque vous privez la
sécurité sociale des ressources
nécessaires de l'argent et bien elle
doit emprunter pour pouvoir continuer à
protéger les retraités les malades les
chômeurs et cetera et elle emprunte via
cette caisse à des taux d'intérêt
supérieur à la dette publique ainsi
ainsi là où quelqu'un de censé mettrait
1000 € pour subvenir à un besoin
identifié vous en mettez 1029 histoire
au passage de gaver des créanciers
privés en conséquence en conséquence on
arrive à la situation où l'on constate
qu'il y a des enfants intubés dans des
couloirs d'hôpitaux et que cette
situation est du exclusivement au fait
que vous ne voulez pas faire cracher le
moindre centime d'euros à Bernard Arnaud
elle est du au fait que vous augmentez
de 300 millions d'euros la clause de
sauvegarde c'est-à-dire la marge que les
établissements de production
pharmaceutique ont le droit d'empocher
lorsqu'ils mettent sur le marché des
médicament remboursa vous ne trouvez
rien non plus à redire au salaire
exorbitant de certains PDG je pense à
Paul Hudson àanofi qui a empoché 9
millions d'euros l'équivalent du salaire
annuel de 400 opérateurs qui eux
pourraient se rendre utile au plus grand
nombre en produisant des
médicaments décidément décidément nous
av'avons pas les mêmes amis avec votre
texte les assurés les malades
souffriront tandis qu'il y aura des
gagnants effectivement des laboratoires
et des actionnaires c'est votre doctrine
nous la respectons mais par souci de
cohérence vous devez partir avec elle
d'autant que ce projet sur lequel vous
déposez le 493 n'inspire aucune
confiance puisqu'il est constitué de
promesses il est en l'état déjà affreux
mais sera peut-être pire c'est ça que
nous apprenons ces derniers jours vous
avez abendonné durant les débats la taxe
de 50 centimes sur les boîtes de
médicaments le plafonnement de
l'indemnisation des l'accident du
travail ou le détournement en douce des
fonds de laagir Arco allez-vous utiliser
le 493 pour les réintroduire malgré tout
le monde dans ce texte vous ne répondez
pas depuis une semaine c'est donc une
question d'honnêteté ou d'hypocrisie les
hypocrites doivent ent partir c'est
vous car même lorsque vous promettez
quelque chose par biais de 493 vous
arrivez à trahir vos propres engagements
c'est tout de même assez extraordinaire
le précédent budget de la Sécurité
sociale prévoyait des rapports sur le
déficit des épad sur les exclus du
sigure sur la prestation de compensation
handicap rien rien vous n'avez rien
rendu pour empêcher la représentation
nationale d'avancer sur ces sujets et
bien évidemment protéger les quelques
officines privées qui en font leur beur
ou bien alors lorsque vous inventez un
dispositif vous organisez son propre
dépérissement regardez l'entretien
post-natal précoce par exemple instauré
par votre budget 2022 alors que le
suicide est la seconde cause de
mortalité chez les jeunes mères alors
que la dépression postpartom cause des
souffrances à des millions de personnes
sur depuis une décennie et bien vous
parvenez à inventer un entretien de
prévention obligatoire qui leurit
facturé c'est une situation tout à fait
extraordinaire où d'une main vous donner
quelque chose et de l'autre vous vous
assurer que ce soit inaccessible à celle
auxquell il est destiné en somme vous
sabotez vos promesses et c'est la raison
pour laquelle moins de 9 % des femmes
accèdent à l'entretien qui leur est
destiné que ce soit par des inérêts par
manque de sérieux ou juste parce que
vous êtes despinces d qu'il s'agit de
faire de la protection sociale vous
devez partir et cette motion de censure
le
permet collègu de droite nous savons
collègu presque au singulier de droite
nous savons que
l'actualité vous amène à vous poser la
question de censure et bien vous pouvez
le faire aujourd'hui en protégeant vos
électeurs plutôt qu'en appant sur la
tête des étrangers choisissez c'est
l'occasion alors il ne reste à ce stade
au gouvernement plus qu'un argument
l'absence d'alternative rassurez-vous je
tiens à la main et à votre disposition
le contrebudget PLFSS de la France
insoumise celui qui donne écho et donne
suite à toutes les revendications du
pays vis-à-vis de sa sécurité social
bref concluons la semaine dernière un
ministre cité le poète Aragon à mon tour
de lui répondre
comme le dit le poète nous étions faits
pour être libr nous étions fait pour
être heureux et si ce n'est pas nous la
faute montrez-moi les meneurs de jeu les
meneurs de jeu c'est vous nous vous
demandons de partir c'est l'occasion par
la motion de
censure je vous
remerci la parole est à Monsieur Pierre
Merin pour le groupe rassemblement
national pour une durée de 15
[Applaudissements]
minutes
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues madame la
Première ministre vous ne connaissez par
cœur qu'un seul alinéa de la
Constitution le 493 mais vous avez
oublié l'esprit et l'âme du texte
suprême de notre République notre
République chers collègues est un pacte
qui unit les citoyens français à ses
représentant c'est le gouvernement du
peuple par le peuple et pour le peuple
vous feriez mieux de relire l'article 2
de notre Constitution plutôt que
d'enchaîner les 493 à force
d'autoritarisme technocratique vous avez
oublié qu'une nation n'avance qu'avec
ses citoyens à force de 493 vous êtes
devenu madame la Première ministre une
simple prestataire au service de
l'autoritarisme
présidentiel cela cela fait 14 fois
madame le Premier ministre que vous
interromp le processus législatif et
pour le projet de loi de finance la
dernière fois vous n'avez même pas dénié
le moindre amendement être débattu en
séance vous avez donc muselé la
démocratie parlementaire et donc le
peuple français à notre tour madame la
Première ministre de considérer que
factuellement votre autoritarisme
pourrait vous placer en dehors de
l'Arque
républicain si encore votre projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale répondait aux enjeux de la
tiermondisation de notre système de
santé mais non encore raté les déserts
médicaux continueront de s'étendre la la
détresse des soignants demeurera intacte
et le déficit de notre sécurité sociale
va continuer à se creuser vous ne savez
même pas comment vous allez financer
votre budget de la Sécurité sociale vous
n'avez par exemple pas indexé le
financement des hôpitaux sur l'inflation
il manque dans ce budget 1,5 milliard
d'euros pour que ces structures puissent
faire face à l'explosion des charges
liées à l'inflation et au coût
énergétique et comme par â magie le
ministre de la Santé annonce la la
semaine dernière rediscutter financement
donc vous déclenchez un 493 sur un texte
qui ne sera même pas le texte final cela
relève d'une forme d'insincérité et
d'opacité qui sont clairement l'une de
vos marques de fabrique vous ne portez
aucune vision pour remédier à la
bureaucratisation de nos hôpitaux aucune
vision pour rapprocher la médecine de
ville et les hôpitaux aucune vision pour
rapprocher aucune vision pour améliorer
les conditions de travail des soignants
et remédier à la crise des vocations
aucune vision pour inverser la tendance
des 100000 lit d'hôpitaux fermés depuis
20 ans à l'instar de tant d'autres
domaines la concentration de très
nombreux soins hospitaliers dans les
grandes métropole encore une fois en
raison de logique comptable indigne du
service public a aussi eu pour effet de
mettre en péril le tissu d'hôpitaux de
proximité la conséquence est gravissime
le nombre de Français qui renoncent aux
soins y compris d'urgence ne cesse de
croîre vous traitez les déserts médicaux
avec une nonchalence très décalée au
regard de l'urgence vitale il y a 50 ans
les Français bénéficiaient de 318
médecins pour 100000 habitants
aujourd'hui il nen reste plus que 162 la
tiermondisation médicale de la France
est une réalité que vous accompagnez
depuis 6 ans le sujet devrait pourtant
intéresser très for très fortement le
ministre de la Santé puisque nous
partageons le même territoire d'élection
dans le gare monsieur le ministre de la
Santé monsieur le ministre de la Santé
vous êtes élu de Saint-Hilaire de
bretmass dans l'agglomération d'Alès
vous savez peut-être que l'association
des maères ruraux a conduit une étude en
2022 selon laquelle il manquerait au
moins 22 médecins dans le bassin àaisien
il en manque également 11 à pon
Saint-Esprit dans le gare rodanien quand
et comment allez-vous inverser la
tendance certainement pas avec vos
logiques comptables certainement pas
avec vos tableaux Excel et vos
PowerPoint certainement pas avec les
études de mckinse bref certainement pas
avec ce budget de la Sécurité sociale
en en revanche en revanche madame la
Première ministre peut-être que la
lecture du programme sur la santé de
Marine Le Pen pourrait à profit vous
inspirer le rassemblement national a
proposé de nombreuses mesures pour
redonner du souffle à notre système de
santé revalorisation du salairirees des
soignants ouverture de nouvelles places
dans les facultés de médecine et les
écoles d'infirmière création d'une
filière distincte aux urgences pour les
personnes âgées modulation à la hausse
de la consultation en fonction du lieu
d'installation des médecins pour
remédier au déser médicaux
transformation de l'aide médicale d'État
en dispositif de soins d'urgence carte
Vitale biométrique pour lutter contre la
fraude et cetera et cetera le programme
de Marine Le Pen est plétorique pour
redresser notre système de santé mais
par- deà ce projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale la représentation
nationale doit vous censurer pour
l'ensemble de votre œuvre parce que
Madame la premierre ministre pour
reprendre le plus élémentaire des
principes républicains vous n'êtes pas
le gouvernant du peuple par le peuple
vous êtes le gouvernement d'une minorité
de français vous êtes la chef de la
minorité présidentielle et ne devez
votre salut qu'aux fausses oppositions
qui siègent sur ses bancs la fausse
opposition de gauche qui refuse par
sectarisme de voter lesmotion du
rassemblement national la fausse
opposition de droite des parlementaires
au singulier en effet effrayé d'une
dissolution qui leur coûterait de
nombreux sièges les Français l'ont déjà
compris la seule opposition déterminée
et constante se trouve sur ces bancs
c'est le rassemblement national avec
Marine Le Pen qui n'a qu'une seule
boussole la France et le peuple
français vous êtes aussi le gouvernement
de l'extrême gauche avant de devenir
minoritaire à l'Assemblée nationale
Emmanuel Macron avait été élu par défaut
en 2022 grâce aux insoumis grâce aux
écologistes grâce aux communistes et
grâce aux socialistes il est bon de
rappeler madame la Première ministre que
la socialiste que vous êtes doit sa
place à ceux qui at les flammes de la
division de notre pays à ceux qui
refusent de condamner des actes
terroristes à ceux qui manifestent avec
des groupuscules islamiste séparatiste
en guise d'illustration de votre belle
alliance avec l'extrême gauche je je
voudrais rappeler que votre président de
la commission des lois au mois de
septembre a signé une tribune dans
Libération avec les communistes pour
demander la régularisation des
travailleurs clestin cela signifie que
votre président de la commission des
lois soutient dehors la loi mais cela
signifie également que le président
macroniste de la commission des lois
s'allie avec les communistes qui ont
défendu l'an dernier une proposition de
résolution visant à reconnaître que
l'État d'Israël est un régime
d'aparthide madame la Première ministre
vous voici confondu dans vos
accointances socialistes avec une
extrême gauche à la dérive avec de tels
amis avec un tel statut minoritaire dans
notre pays vous ne sauriez être le
gouvernement du peuple et par le peuple
mais encore vous étiez un gouvernement
pour le peuple mais là encore votre
bilan désastreux démontre plutôt que
vous êtes un gouvernement contre le
peuple et contre les intérêts de la
France et des Français hier à Pont
Saint-Esprit dans ma circonscription
s'est déroulé une scène de guerre civile
une fusiade a causé la mort de deux
personnes et deux autres sont gravement
blessés un tel événement est devenu
presque quotidien dans la France
d'Emmanuel Macron cela fait 6 ans que
vous êtes au pouvoir et les chiffres de
la délinquence explosent les Français
souffrent les Français en ont les
Français ne veulent plus de ce
gouvernement hors sol le ministre
d'armanin ce monsieur fermeté dans le
verbe mais qui est plutôt monsieur
l'xisme dans les dans les actes présente
un terrible bilan l'ensauvagement de la
société se traduit en chiffres concrets
des émeut à 800 millions d'euros de
dégâts en juillet dernier 8 % de hausse
des homicides et 15 % de hausse des
coups et blessures en 2022 une
augmentation de 27 % de l'immigration
mais surtout le visage le visage qui
restera de ceux qui ont perdu la vie à
cause de votre laxisme notamment quant à
l'expulsion de ces personnes dangereuses
qui n'ont rien à faire sur notre
territoire sur les grands enjeux de
notre siècle madame la Première ministre
vous n'avez cessé de faire des mauvais
choix et de vous contredire
systématiquement sur l'énergie par
exemple votre premier mandat a été
consacré à fragiliser méthodiquement et
et avec génie notre filière nucléaire
avec la fermeture de Fessenheim et le
sous-investissement dans nos
infrastructures vous avez communié à
L'Idéologie allemande des énergies
renouvelables qui ont mis en péril notre
souveraineté énergétique le pouvoir
d'achat des Français et la transition
écologique puisque cette gabj vous a
conduit à rouvrir une centrale à charbon
et à importer de l'électricité allemande
produite avec des centrales à
charbon vous êtes le gouvernement de la
brutalité sociales et des super
profiteurs pendant que vous avez
supprimé l'impôt sur la fortune vous
vous ponctionnez les automobiliste alors
que nous réclamons depuis des mois au
rassemblement national et avec Marine Le
Pen la baisse de la TVA sur l'énergie
l'inflation galope et pendant ce temps
vous laissez les super profiteurs des
autoroutes augmenter les prix des péages
merci pour les Français qui travaillent
la crise du logement est aujourd'hui un
enjeu de société majeur et pourtant en
2030 vous allez faire sortir plus de 40
% des logement du parc locatif avec
votre diagnostic de performance
énergétique vous allez donc mettre des
Français à la rue et vous allez ruiner
les propriétaires de ce pays les
propriétaires les plus modestes vous
êtes le gouvernement des puissants
contre les plus modestes vous êtes fort
avec les faibles et faibles avec les
forts vous avez imposé une réforme des
retraite inepte et brutal pour les plus
modestes et pour les femmes dans le même
temps vous n'êtes pas capable de lutter
contre la fraude fiscale et sociale qui
pourrait rapporter selon les estimations
à l'état entre 30 et 50 milliards
d'euros fort avec les faibles faible
avec les fort 6 ans de macronisme c'est
aussi 700 milliards d'euros de dett
laissé à nos enfants c'est aussi un
déficit commercial multiplié par 3
malgré votre autosatisfaction permanente
voilà le bilan des prétendus Mozart de
la
finance je ne pourrais faire la liste
complète des absurdités de votre
gouvernement qui marche sur la tête
brutalité sociale tiermondisation de la
France incompétence et technocratie
autoritaire voilà ce qui qui constitue
le macroniste le macronisme pardon avec
votre écologie punitive vos zones à
faibles émissions ZFE et vos et votre
métropolisation qui essort nos
territoires ruraux vous faites acte de
séparatisme territorial et social à
l'égard de millions de français Madame
la première ministre vous dirigez un
gouvernement qui met la France à l'arrêt
vous êtes comptable d'une France
multifracturé multiconflictuel et
multiendetté et largement appauvri cela
fait 6 ans que vous êtes au pouvoir 6
ans que vous essurez les Français quand
je pense que il reste 4 ans oui mais 10
minutes oui mais il reste 4 ans de
macronisme à supporter je vous assure
que ça va être long aussi he mais
l'espérance que nous portons justifie de
combattre politique de vous combattre
politiquement sans relâche l'espérance
de voir rentrer Marine Le Pen à l'Élysée
en 2027 pour redresser et apaiser la
France cela nous donne le courage de
notre travail et de nos conviction le 9
juin prochain nous avons aussi
l'espérance de vous sanctionner
largement dans les ures avec Jordan
bardellaa vivement le 9 juin 2024
vivement le mois de mai 2027 pour enfin
sortir la France du cauchemar que vous
lui faites vivre vous l'aurez compris
madame la Première ministre je ne vous
remercie pas pour votre action politique
en revanche je vous remercie chers
collègues pour votre
attention je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Yannick neuder pour le groupe les
républicains et pour une durée de 10
minutes
présidente madame la présidente madame
la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègu sans surprise n nous retrouvons
ce lundi pour examiner deux motions de
censure suite Madame Le Pen madameame la
première ministre à votre
40e voyz vous me perturbez même quand
vous descendez les
marches s suite madame la Première
ministre à votre 14e 493 si cette
situation devient usuelle puisque les
Français n'ont pas souhaité vous donner
une majorité dans cet hémicycle le
moment que vous avez choisi pour
déclencher cet outils constitutionnels
nous pose un réel problème démocratique
un jour seulement un jour seulement pour
discuter en séance publique du PLFSS
2024 un texte pourtant structurant de
notre système de santé pour l'année à
venir un jour à peine pour débat des
priorités pour la France en terme de
politique sanitaire et sociale car avant
d'être un exercice budgétaire le budget
de la Sécurité sociale est le réceptacle
des attentes des inquiétudes et des
espéran de nos compatriotes en terme de
santé le cœur de notre travail de
députés aurait donc été ici de relayer
les demandes des acteurs du soin du
médicossocial des partenaires sociaux et
des Français dans leur ensemble et notre
seul moyen de le faire c'est en
défendant nos amendements ici même au
sein de cet hémicycle par nos
amendements nous voulions parler de
santé publique de prévention de
politique familiale de mesures pour le
grand âge et la dépendance de soins
palliatifs ou encore d'attractivité des
métiers du soin par nos amendements nous
aurions souhaité améliorer le sort des
Familles de France dans l'accès aux
soins mais aussi améliorer le déficit
d'établissements de santé et
médicau-sociaux du public et du privé ou
encore nous faire le relais des
paramédicaux qui maillent l'ensemble du
territoire tout en prenant de plein
fouet l'inflation or vous nous avez
privé de débattre sur ces sujets
fondamentaux pour l'équilibre de notre
système de soins vous nous av pas permis
d'échanger suffisamment sur ce texte
pourtant l'un des plus importants de
notre calendrier parlementaire
l'anticipation par les députés de cette
situation déjà connue l'année dernière
nous a conduit cette année à rejeter
pour la première fois le PLFSS en
commission des affaires sociales au
demeurant je tiens à remercier sa
présidente madame Charlotte Parmentier
Lecoq pour avoir fait vivre ce débat
ainsi que la rapporteur générale
Stéphanie Rist qui apporter avec
patience beaucoup d'indications précises
madame la Première ministre je ne
conteste ni ni votre légitimité ni votre
droit constitutionnel de courir au 493
mais je conteste le timing choisi à
l'heure où les Français démontre un réel
manque de confiance à l'égard du pouvoir
politique alors vous proposez de
reprendre des amendements des
oppositions ici et là pour ensuite vous
prévaloir de certaines convergences mais
ils ne sont pas majeurs les Français ne
s'y méprendront pas et je crains que
cette attitude renforce leur défiance à
votre égard tout cela se révèle donc
assez décevant pour les députés de tous
les groupes qui travaille sur ce PLFSS
depuis plusieurs semaines mais venez-ons
tout de même au fond sur ce budget car
quand c'est généré de loin c'est loin
d'être géré j'ai donc plusieurs regrets
mais j'en évoqueraici que quatre
permettez-moi de commencer par la
branche famille ça devrait pourtant être
la priorité absolue du gouvernement à
l'heure où la natalité et le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages s'effondrent la
natalité est au plus bas depuis la
Seconde Guerre mondiale si Madame la
Ministre Aurore Berger a exprimé sa
bonne volonté pour la politique
familiale il n'a rien de concret dans ce
PLFSS pourquoi ne pas avoir répondu à
notre appel à rétablir l'universalité
des allocations familiales pourquoi ne
pas avoir répondu à notre appel de
réhausser le ccient familial pourquoi ne
pas avoir honoré votre promesse de
réformer le congé parental dans ce PLFSS
pour que celui-ci soit mieux rémunéré
mon deuxième regret concerne la
dépendance et le grand âge dans ce PLFSS
la branche autonomie n'est toujours pas
suffisamment financé pendant que la
branche vieillesse reste toujours
frasilisée victime de son inflation
pourtant le virage domiciliaire devrait
être notre objectif commun sinon l'une
des priorités du gouvernement j'ose
espérer madame la Première ministre que
la question de nos aidé ne sera pas
attribuée à la seule ministre firmain
lebaudeau avec sa loi sur la fin de vie
à ce sujet rien non plus sur les soins
palliatifs alors que la Cour des comptes
estime que les besoins seraient de
l'ordre de 1,5 milliards d'euros quelle
belle occasion manqué de faire grâce à
ce PLFSS un grand plan de développement
des soins palliatifs en France quant à
mon 3ème point c'est malheureusement la
stratégie du gouvernement à faire des
économies sur la santé des Français
suppression par décret des financements
pour certains dispositifs visant à
traiter les AVC ou les cancers des
remboursements des soins dentaires qui
débouchera sur une augmentation du prix
des mutuels de 10 % également effectué
par décret augmentation des franchises
médicales tantôt c'est oui tantôt ses
nonom on n'y comprend plus bien
grand-chose tout comme les ponctions
agirarco d'ailleurs qui croireent voilà
donc que non seulement ce PLFSS est
insincère financièrement mais il est
également politiquement puisque vous ne
dites pas au français ce que vous allez
leur demander de payer en plus enfin mon
dernier point concerne la lutte contre
la fraude sociale plutôt que des
économies sur la santé des français où
est dans ce péfesss la vraie chasse à la
fraude sociale celui-ci avait été estimé
par Gabriel hatal à près de 8 milliards
d'euros par an quid de la carte Vitale
biométrique que nous réclamons de depuis
longtemps car en effet s'il y a une
chose que nous voulons aux républicains
c'est que les français arrêtent de payer
pour ceux qui fraudent avant de terminer
je souhaite pointer un énième non dit
pardon de nos courtes discussions la
situation de nos internes de médecine
qui sont actuellement exclus de la
pérénisation de la revalorisation des
gardes de 50 %. monsieur le ministre
nous avons besoin de clarté et
d'engagement pouvez-vous nous garantir
que nos étudiants en médecine qui
tiennent eux aussi notre système de
santé seront revalorisés pour leur garde
et leurs astreintes voilà mes chers
collègues des sujets importants dont
nous aurions dû parler des sujets
structurels et indispensables pour nos
concitoyens et qui impose de ne pas
enjamber l'Assemblée nationale par un
493 à ce sujet je me tourne vers les
dépositaire des deux motions de censure
que nous examinons actuellement par ces
motions vous exprimez votre
mécontentement que le Gouvernement
courscircuite l'Assemblée nationale et
de ce point de vue-là vous avez raison
toutefois
toutefois permettez-moi de souligner
votre contradiction en vous rappelant
que vous êtes les mêmes à avoir déposé
des motions de rejet préalable à
l'examen du PLFSS et dont la finalité
aurait été exactement la même qu'un 493
c'est-à-dire enjamber l'Assemblée
nationale en envoyant directement le
texte au Sénat pour en revenir à vos
motions de censure de ce jour celle-ci
aurait deux conséquences possibles soit
remplacer madame borne et le
gouvernement par une madame borne bis et
un gouvernement bis et ça ça ne nous
intéresse pas ça serait une mascarade ou
alors ou alors ouvrir les portes de
Matignon à Jean-Luc Mélenchon et ça nous
le combattrons avec toutes nos
forces mais outre vos manœuvres
politiciennes qui d'ailleurs nous font
perdre beaucoup de temps les
républicains nous souhaitons incarner
une troisième voix la voix du débat
constructif utile à la France ce que
nous aurions voulu c'était donc de
débattre des problème que rencontrent
les Français dans leur quotidien dans
nos
circonscriptions ce que nous aurions
voulu c'était de défendre nos
amendements au service des Français en
fait ce que nous aurions voulu c'était
de faire notre travail de législateur
dans l'intérêt de celui qui nous a élu à
cette fonction le peuple de France je
vous
remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Nicolas turquois pour le groupe
démocrate pour une durée de 15
minutes
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les membres du gouvernement chers
collègues nous sommes ici pour examiner
à nouveau deux motions de censure déposé
par le rassemblement national et la
France àoumise suite au recours que vous
avez fait fait madame la Première
ministre à l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution la semaine dernière lors de
l'examen de la partie recette du projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale je viens de dire examiner à
nouveau car la pratique pour ces deux
formations relève du systématique quand
un texte est présenté il dépose une
motion de rejet quand un article est
examiné il y a un amendement de
suppression quand tout cela a échoué
nous devons faire face à des centaines
d'amendements voire davantage pour
empêcher l'examen au fond des
textes ici en l'occurrence le but est
d'empêcher de donner à la France un
budget pour faire fonctionner les
hôpitaux les établissements pour
personnes âgées ou celles en situation
de handicap pour financer la médecine de
ville les examens médicaux pour régler
les pensions de retraite ou les
allocations de solidarité pour n'en
citer que quelques-uns alors oui madame
la Première ministre vous avez eu raison
d'actionner en responsabilité l'article
49 alinéa
3 nous ne pouvons nous permettre de
priver les Français de ce dispositif de
solidarité sans équivalent dans le monde
et nous ne pouvons nous permettre de
menacer les centaines de milliers de nos
concitoyens qui uvre chaque jour pour la
santé et l'accompagnement médico-social
dans notre
pays le président Matth m'a confié la
responsabilité de m'exprimer au nom du
groupe démocrate sur la motion de
censure je le remercie vivement de sa
bien évidemment nous ne nous associerons
pas à cette motion de censure mais plus
encore nous voulons la
dénoncer cela fait maintenant plus de 6
ans que je suis député et pour autant
certaines pratiques politiques
m'étonnent encore et me sidère en tant
que
député nous avons tous ici l'honneur de
représenter nos concitoyens et d'en
défendre les intérêt certains députés
sont dans la majorité et d'autres sont
dans l'opposition jus j là tout est
logique par contre il est inconcevable
pour nous d'être 5 ans c'est-à-dire un
lustre au sens ancien du terme sans agir
pour améliorer la situation modestement
soit-il être dans l'opposition n'est pas
synonyme d'inaction programmé en
rentrant dans le débat en creusant les
sujets il y a la place pour agir
concrètement pour nos
concitoyens bien sûr le la est donné par
la majorité en place mais il est si on
veut s'en donner les moyens d'infléchir
des dispositions ou d'initier des
mesures utiles à
tous vous avez choisi une autre forme
d'action celle de la paralysie du rejet
en bloc de la tension permanente de
l'exacerbation des uns contre les autres
les salariés contre leurs employeurs les
personnes d'origine étrangère contre les
Français de souche la litanie peut être
longue mais je le dis ici bien posément
elle est stérile votre projet c'est le
le bazar absolu contre la promesse
d'être élu et d'agir en
2027 à votre place j'éviterai bien de
parer sur 2027 car un horizon de 4 ans
est une éternité en politique mais
surtout comment peut-on dire au français
et notamment au plus fragiles
soutenez-nous et on va commencer à
s'occuper de vous dans 4 ans il faudrait
que je lise les statuts de vos
mouvements mais vous devez largement
partager la maxime pourquoi faire
aujourd'hui ce que l'on peut remettre à
plus
tard à travers ces motions censure qui
suivent les palanqués de motions de
rejet et d'amendement de suppression
vous n'avez aucune ambition d'améliorer
le sort des Français dès aujourd'hui
c'est profondément regrettable alors
certes on peut dire que vos pratiques
ont été celles de la plupart des
oppositions dans l'histoire de la
République même si elles n'ont pas été
aussi
systématiques mais quel est le sens de
vouloir bloquer et de ne contribuer à
rien pendant 5 ans il y a parmi vous des
femmes et des hommes qui ont des des
expertises spécifiques sur certains
sujets et qui pourrai faire œuvre utile
en amendement tel ou tel article mais
par opposition partisane vous vous y
refusez et préférez agiter le pays
pendant 5 ans donc 5 ans d'inutilité
pour vous 5 ans d'inutilité pour les
Français 5 ans abîmé la France voilà ce
dont les motions de censure sont le
symbole mais au fait avez-vous vu sur
quoi vous avez déposé une motion de
censure
sur un PLFSS qui pilote un/ers de la
richesse nationale à vous les gens de
gauche d'ailleurs bien peu nombreux qui
dénoncent à corp et à cri la
privatisation de la santé l'écroulement
des solidarité l'abandon de nos
concitoyens les plus fragiles vous êtes
dans l'incapacité de nous citer un pays
qui a construit de telles
solidarité dans mon groupe nous croyons
beaucoup à la valeur de l'exemple
montrez-nous des pays aussi ambitieux en
matière de protection sociale et nous y
regarderons de plus près avec grand
intérêt bien sûr sur telle ou telle
thématique il y a des politiques
publiques plus abouties ici ou là mais
il n'y a pas de protection sociale aussi
systémique qu'en France nous devrions en
être fiers et vous vous contribuez à en
saperer les
fondements cette motion de censure
s'attaque à un objectif national de
dépense de l'assurance maladie le fameux
onondam qui va progresser de 3,2 % alors
que l'inflation est prévue autour de 2,5
% en
2024 c'est tout simplement 7 milliards
de plus que l'année
précédente pour resituer les ordres de
grandeur l'ONDAM était de 190 milliards
en 2017 il atteindra 255 milliards en
2023 vous allez donc voter contre cette
augmentation c'est le sens profond de
votre
démarche
même si cliniquement oserais-je dire la
motion de censure ne porte que sur la
partie recette du PLFSS elle s'attaque
Infiné aux dépenses qui ne pourront être
financé en rejetant ce
texte et donc j'en déduis par exemple
que tout l'aspect prévention du texte
n'est pas
important la la vaccination systématique
à 11 ans contre le papillovirus ce n'est
donc rien l'accès au préservatif à la
protection menstruelle pour nos jeunes
concitoyens ce n'est donc rien
l'organisation de la permanence des
soins pour les urgences dentaires ce
n'est donc rien non plus la possibilité
de bon sens donner aux pharmaciens de
faire des tests rapides pour
diagnostiquer les cystites ou les
angines et éviter les antibiotiques ce
n'est toujours
rien le dépistage précoce des enfants en
situation de handicap et donc la
capacité ce n'est donc rien pour vous
les professionnels de santé de l'hôpital
seront heureux de savoir que la
majoration des gardes de 50 % auquels se
rajouteront 25 % la nuit et 20 % le les
dimanches et jours fériers ce n'est rien
à vos yeux les conseils départementaux
qui dénoncent régulièrement la
complexité de l'articulation des
forfaits soins et des forfaits dépendan
seront assurément ravis de constater que
l'expérimentation prévu pour fusionner
ces deux forfaits ne sont rien pour vous
la lutte contre la fraude si souvent
évoquée sur ma droite comme étant la
merre des batailles et qui aurait pu
être renforcé par des amendements
construits n'est finalement rien puisque
vous déposez une motion de censure je
pourrais continuer longtemps sur la
liste des avancés de ce PLFSS que vous
voulez renvoyer aux
oubliettes vous pourriez contribuer à
les amplifier vous avez choisi de les
écraser d'un revers de la main madame la
Première ministre je vous remercie et à
travers vous les membres du gouvernement
pour nous avoir proposé ce PLFSS à la
fois ambitieux et
rigoureux chers collègues les Français
attendent de nous que nous travaillons
ensemble je suis sûr que je suis sûr que
certains parmi vous
l'entendent ne votez pas cette motion de
censure car elle c'est sûr elle ne vaut
rien je vous remercie de votre attention
je vous remercie monsieur
turquois la parole est à Monsieur Jérôme
Gedge pour le groupe socialiste et
apparenté pour une durée de 10 minutes
[Applaudissements]
vous
plaît s'il vous
plaît madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues c'est
le cœur lourd et l'âme flétrie par la
violence du monde que je monte à cette
tribune n'y a-t-il pas quelque chose
de dérisoire alors que le monde
s'embrase à poursuivre ce mauvais
théâtre institutionnel avec un 14e 493
en un an tout juste la guerre s'en lise
en Ukraine et personne n'a oublié les
massacres de bcha et bien sûr les
porommes du 7 octobre dernier en Israël
les otages détenus dont il faut sans
relâche demander la libération
l'explosion des actes antisémites en
France et partout dans le monde comme
hier au Dagestan cette terrible
essentialisation du conflit et désormais
nouvelle guerre avec déjà des milliers
de victimes civiles tué ou blessé parmi
la population de Gaza lors de
l'intervention militaire israélienne pas
de cesser le feu ni de trêve humanitaire
un blocus renforcé côté israélien
égyptien privant les populations des
ressources nécessaires pour vivre tout
est effrayant tout est déprimant tout
est désespérant mais pourtant une ligne
de crête fragile est nécessaire la
condamnation des terroristes du ramas et
la nécessité de les stopper
définitivement dans leur entreprise
mortifère le droit indéfectible à
l'existence à la sécurité d'Israël qui
doit s'exercer dans les limites du droit
international et du droit humanitaire de
la guerre le droit imprescriptible des
Palestiniens à disposer enfin de leur
état ce qui passe d'abord par la fin de
la colonisation et nécessitera la
démocratisation le institutions pour une
solution à deux états et dans l'immédiat
évidemment le droit à la protection pour
les populations civiles à Gaza nous
pleurons chaque victime civile
voyez-vous oui dans ce contexte notre
notre après-midi joué d'avance pourrait
apparaître bien dérisoire et
insignifiante
et pourtant nous sommes là car
voyez-vous la démocratie même imparfaite
même cadenacée par les outils de la 5e
République comme le 493 elle nous oblige
tous et plus encore quand tant la
piétine elle et ses valeurs aux quatre
coins du monde la politique doit
demeurer redevenir l'espace de la
dispute apaisée ne cédant jamais aux
sirènes de la violence à rebours de la
tentation de l'hystérisation et de la
conflictualisation terrain dangereux
quand tout est à ce point inflammable à
rebour d'un manikéisme qui fait perdre
la raison et où l'intelligence et la
complexité s'abîme c'est dans cet état
d'esprit lucide mais pas résigné
exigeant comme tout universaliste
républicain que je me présente devant
vous pour jouer mon rôle de
parlementaire et soutenir à cet instant
la lettre et l'esprit de cette motion de
censure les 493 se suivent et se
ressemblent déjà un sur le PLF et
peut-être tout à l'heure encore un autre
sur le PLFSS qu'il est loin le temps
Madame la première ministre où vous nous
parliez de coconstruction de recherche
de promis il y a 6 mois tout juste vous
nous promettiez 100 jours d'apaisement
vous n'avez depuis qu'accentué
l'épuisement pour la première fois ce
PLFSS a été rejeté en commission des
affaires sociales même vos députés de la
majorité n'étaient pas pleinement
mobilisés preuve qu'ils n'étaiit pas
totalement convaincu du budget proposé
et comment les blâmer car il n'était pas
convaincant voyez-vous pour que la
démocratie fonctionne vous nous devez
d'abord la transparence vous aimez
beaucoup utiliser l'article 493 je vais
vous citer un autre article de la
constitution l'article 24 alinéa 1 que
vous semblez parfois avoir oublié le
Parlement vote la loi il contrôle
l'action du Gouvernement il évalue les
politiques publiques et pour cela nous
avons besoin de la nécessaire
transparence car si vous n'êtes pas
transparent avec les députés alors comme
je l'ai dit l'autre jour dans
l'hémicycle c'est que c'est flou et
quand c'est flou c'est qu'il y a un loup
et dans votre PLFSS il y en a plusieurs
il nous revient donc à cet instant
d'utiliser ce débat de motion de censure
pour nous permettre au moins d'avoir de
votre bouche madame la Première ministre
la réponse à des questions que le débat
parlementaire n'a pas pu permettre de
fournir faute de temps mais surtout
faute de volonté d'être transparent je
vais donc vous poser quatre questions
extrêmement précises sur l'ONDAM le
budget de l'assurance maladie nous vous
demandons la transparence madame la
Première ministre c'est couru d'avance
l'ondame que vous décidez ne sera pas
suffisant notamment pour faire face à la
crise inflationniste et comme en 2023 il
plongera les établissements hospitaliers
les épades les services et
établissements médicaux-sociaux dans le
rouge nous en avons beaucoup parlé ici
entendez la Fédération hospitalière de
France qui comme l'an dernier vous
alerte sur ces insuffisances et pire
l'an dernier déjà vous n'aviez pas voulu
doté de moyens insuffisants que vous
rectifiez mais aussi de manière
insuffisante en cours d'arnée donc ma
question est simple quelle sera la la
rallonge qu'immanquablement vous devrez
apporter comme vous le faites pour 2023
et pourquoi ne pas le faire dès à
présent 2è question très précise sur la
ponction de l'agir Carco vous nous devez
la transparence parce que j'ai posé
plusieurs fois la question ici Thomas
CASNAV n'a pas apporté de réponse si la
négociation que vous appelez de vos vœux
si la négociation que vous appelez de
vos vœux n'aboutit pas entre les
partenaires sociaux pouvez-vous nous
dire oui ou non si vous prendrez un
décret de carence pour imposer de cette
cette ponction et si oui de quel montant
sur les franchises médicales là aussi
vous nous devez la transparence parce
que Aurélien ous nous disait avec
beaucoup de franchises en commission des
affaires sociales et dans la discussion
générale qu'il souhaitait que le débat
ait lieu le problème c'est que le débat
n'a pas eu lieu parce que l'ONDAM tel
qu'il est prévu intègre toujours 800
millions d'euros pour le doublement des
franchises médicales et des
participations forfaitaires mais
personne dans l'hémicycle n'a osé nous
dire oui ou non il y aura un doublement
de cet impôt sur la maladie et personne
ne nous a dit à quelle date donc la
question est simple allez-vous prendre
avant la fin de l'année ou au début de
l'année prochaine un décret permettant
le doublement de ces franchises
médicales assumer cette position et si
vous ne le faites pas ce que nous
souhaitons alors il faut que vous nous
disiez aussi où allez-vous faire les
économies pour tenir cette ondeâme
diminué des 800 millions d'euros tel
qu'il est prévu aujourd'hui la 4ème
question tout aussi franche et directe
porte sur la question du grand âge parce
que là on tourne autour du pot et ça
devient fatigant là aussi vous nous
devez la transparence il paraît madame
la Première ministre que vous cherchez
des sujets de travail transpartisans
mais voyez-vous dans cet hémicycle vous
le voyez toutes les semaines dans les
questions au Gouvernement la situation
des éepades la situation des services à
domicile l'accompagnement des personnes
âgées laassuation des professionnels
préoccupe sur tous les bancs le 11 avril
dernier à l'unanimité les députés dans
cet hémicycle ont voté un amendement à
la proposition de loi dit bien vieillir
pour vous demander enfin une loi de
programmation sur le grand âge parce que
tout le monde a compris que c'est le
vecteur juridique dont nous avons besoin
pour avoir une vision répondant aux
besoins pour pouvoir décliner les
propositions du rapport de ma collègue
Christine pirezbaon et pour pouvoir
avancer en avril dernier le président
Valot madame la Première ministre vous a
écrit pour vous proposer ce travail
transpartisan pas de réponse à un
président de groupe j'en avais alerté le
ministre chargé des Relations avec le
Parlement donc je profite de cette
tribune pour vous poser la question très
claire dans quelques jours votre
Ministre chargé des solidarités et des
familles doit présenter une feuille de
route pour le Bien Vieillir est-ce que
vous l'autorisez parce que j'ai le
sentiment nous sommes plusieurs qu'elle
a très envie d'en avoir l'autorisation
est-ce que vous l'autorisez à préparer
avec l'ensemble de ses collègues
ministres une loi de programmation sur
le grand âge ce serait une annonce utile
à cet instant alors si vous vous n'êtes
pas transparent sur ce que vous allez
faire laissez-moi au moins nous dire ce
que nous nous aurions fait parce que
dans les débats beaucoup nous ont dit
vous n'avez pas de PLFSS alternatif et
bien il se trouve que nous n avons un
parce que face frapp face à l'urgence
qui frappe tous les professionnels de
santé vous vous avez décidé une réponse
double l'injustice et l'austérité notre
réponse elle est double également c'est
la responsabilité et l'audace la
responsabilité c'est un changement de
paradigme c'est gouverné par les besoins
et non pas être obsédé par la seule
maîtrise comptable et budgétaire ce que
vous faisit l'audace c'est de changer de
paradigme en transformant en profondeur
notre système de santé en trouvant des
solutions innovantes pour le pour le
financer et le PLFSS n'est pas n'est
plus le bon outil pour pouvoir le faire
il faudra un un jour que nous nous y
penchions alors je pourrais mais le
temps va me manquer vous décrire les
axes prioritaires évidemment la
reconstruction de l'hôpital public
notamment en changeant en profondeur le
mode de financement de l'hôpital et pas
de manière homéopathique comme vous le
faites avec votre pseudo réforme de la
tarification à l'activité je vais vous
livrer un scoop devant le ministre de la
Santé l'homéopathie madame la Première
ministre ça ne marche pas nous devons
aussi repenser nos politiques de
protection de la petite enfance et créer
un véritable service public de la petite
enfance nous serons là pour
l'accompagner je voudrais aussi insister
comme l'ont fait mes collègues Chantal
Jourdan et Joël aviranier sur la
nécessité d'une politique ambitieuse en
matière de en matière de santé mentale
voilà un sujet de refondation systémique
dont nous avons besoin tant la crise est
majeure 30 % des postes de psychiatrie
vacant 50 % des postes de
pédopsychiatrie le sont aussi il nous
faut réorganiser le secteur du
médicaments en profondeur pour favoriser
la relocalisation et la décabronation de
cette filière notamment en s'appuyant
sur un pôle public du médicament et tout
cela ne pourra se faire qu'en assumant
de nouvelles recettes qui permettent de
rendre plus juste et aussi plus efficace
notre modèle de protection sociale je
prends ici l'exemple d'un travail
transpartisan que vous avez balayé du
revers de la main celui que j'ai conduit
avec mon collègue Marc Ferraci pour
revenir sur les exonérations de
cotisation sociale inutile vous n'en
avez pas voulu c'est bien regrettable
madame la Première
ministre vous
avez il y a peu reproché à Justine Triet
de vous l'avez invité à réfléchir à son
rapport à la réalité après qu'elle ait
parlé de la contestation historique sur
les réformes sur les la réformes des
retraites je vous renvoie le même
conseil réfléchissez à votre rapport à
la réalité c'est l'urgence dans nos
hôpitaux dans nos épades et au fait ce
beau film Justine trier s'appelle
anatomie d'une chute madame la Première
ministre je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Frédéric Valtou
pour le groupe horizon et apparenté pour
une durée de 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre Mesdames et Messieurs
les les ministres mes chers collègues
alors même si le scénario de cette
nouvelle motion de censure est écrit
d'avance j'ai lu et écouté avec ce qui
nous était dit et écrit par les
rédacteurs de de ces deux
motions nous avons entendu la triste
litanie du tout va mal que notre système
est dans un état catastrophique que plus
personne ne veut travailler à l'hôpital
que les lits ferm que les épades sont
maltraitants que le la misère est à tous
les étages et cetera et cetera ai-je lu
ou entendu un projet alternatif qui
puisse réunir les uns et les autres et
faire majorité au sein de cet hémicycle
absolument pas et je lu a entendu un
projet alternatif qui dessinerait la
voix d'un consensus ou en tout le cas
d'une majorité absolument pas ce qui est
ce qui vous importe c'est de s'opposer
de s'opposer plus que de construire ça a
été rappelé par plusieurs des précédents
orateurs et pour un texte qui tend à
améliorer la santé des Français votre
volonté de blocage ne rime plus à rien
non balayer d'un revers de main un
budget qui soutend toutes nos politiques
sociales n'a jamais été une solution en
tout cas ne l'est pas pour les Français
vous mentionnez par exemple la gestion
par la
pénurie mais euh je veux dire qu'aucun
gouvernement ne s'était attelé euh
depuis 2017 autant à la lutte contre ces
pénuries et à ce à tous les niveaux la
pénurie de médecin mais c'est la
majorité présidentielle qui pendant le
précédent quinquena a mis fin au numérus
closusus qui datait d'il y a plus de 30
40 ans et qui a inversé la cour de la
démographie des de formation des
médecins la pénurier des médicaments la
pénurie les les pénuries ne sont pas
propres à notre pays et la France trouve
des solutions concrètes par par la
déclinaison d'un plan en particulier sur
les antibiotiques sur toute la chaîne de
fabrication de ces médicaments jusqu'à
la capacité assurer une production
nationale dans certains cas la pénurie
de lit mais la baisse du nombre de lit
est une réalité qui doit être regardée
sans démagogie elle résulte d'abord d'un
manque de soignants et quand les
soignants reviennent les lits réouvrent
c'est le cas on l'a vu à la PHP ces
dernières semaines mais c'est aussi le
résultat de la mutation de l'offre avec
une augmentation de l'hospitalisation en
ambulatoire mieux adapté à nos
nombreuses prises en charge aujourd'hui
plus personne sauf vous ne parle de la
ne juge plus la qualité d'un système de
santé et son efficience en fonction du
nombre de lit vous affirmez que les
revalorisations des prestations sociales
sont insuffisantes et tardives mais plus
de 630 milliards d'euros sont prévus en
2024 pour la sécurité sociale 630
milliards pour la santé pour les
familles 630 milliards pour l'autonomie
pour la déépendance pour le handicap
c'est 40 milliards de plus en seulement
2 ans vous ne rappelez pas non plus que
la France reste le premier pays
européens pour les dépenses de
protection sociale plus de 33 % du PIB y
sont consacrés quand la moyenne
européenne est à moins de 30 % 12350 €
par habitant soit 2000 de plus que la
moyenne de l'Europe même si aujourd'hui
l'excellence de notre système de santé
est battu en brèche par les nombreuses
crises qu' l'affectent et que personne
ne ne conteste c'est fondamentaux
c'est-à-dire un système dans lequel
cohabite public et privé financé par la
solidarité nationale pour garantir
l'accès à tous et bien ces fondamentaux
sont un bien précieux dont il nous
revient de garantir la pérenité pour les
générations futures le gouvernement le
sait et agit en conséquence soutenu par
notre majorité les évolutions engagées
depuis 2017 sont nombreuses la majorité
présidentielle a su ouvrir la voie des
réformes volontaristes d'envergure après
des décennies de politique du rabot pour
la première fois les actes ont été pris
en adéquation avec les engagements du
Président de la République quel
gouvernement a lancé un plan
d'investissement chiffré à à 19
milliards d'euros dans le le financement
dere système hospitalier et quel autre
gouvernement a décidé une hausse de
salaire inédite avec le segéure de la
santé quel gouvernement a augmenté de 50
milliards en 3 ans 50 milliards d'euros
en 3 ans le budget consacré à la santé
ce rattrapage considérable était
nécessaire et beaucoup de nos soignants
ont reconnu ce qui a été fait avec le
segégure en terme de rémunération avec
des revalorisations qui ont amélioré des
vies dans beaucoup d'endroits de 180 à
400 € nets par mois alors non notre
majorité présidentielle n'a pas à rougi
soyons fierers de l'investissement
inédit de notre pays en matière de santé
fait ces dernières années notre notre
modèle de protection sociale qui
rencontre ses défis et ses difficultés
nous ne le nions pas fait encore la
fierté de notre pays la fierté de tous
ceux qui travaillent au quotidien je
suis fier de notre protection sociale
fier de nos services publics qui
prennent en charge les plus fragiles et
ceux qui en ont besoin fier de nos
hôpitaux et de ceux qui travaillent vous
qualifiez le gouvernement
d'irresponsable mais c'est vos motions
répétées vos positions budgétaires
irréalistes qui sont irresponsables la
responsabilité c'est de rechercher
l'équilibre de non comptes sociaux pas
pour le plaisir d'une équation qui
serait équilibrée non pour garantir la
pérenité de ce système social pour
assurer que chaque euro des Français est
ainsi dépensé de façon juste et efficace
mais cela ne doit pas nous faire pour
autant oublier le constant besoin de
réforme de transformation pour s'adapter
aux nouveaux enjeux dont notre système
doit faire face c'est au prix d'audace
et de ténacité que nous redonnerons
toute son Excellence à notre système de
santé que nous attirerons les jeunes
générations vers les métiers du soin que
nous répondrons de manière plus
satisfaisante aux besoins des Français
et l'excellence de notre système ne peut
renaître qu'à travers des réformes
structurelles au premier rang desquelles
la réforme du système de financement
notre système de santé produit des
dépenses inutiles le président de la
République lui-même en avait fait ce
constat clair en septembre 2018 à
l'occasion du lancement de la stratégie
mass santé 2022 en déclarant que près du
tiers des dépenses dans notre système de
santé était inutile indu ou non per
pertinente je partage moi-même ce
constat depuis des années par ailleurs
le modèle de tarification à l'activité
perçu comme l'alpha et l'oméga d'un
financement du système hospitalier et
des soins de ville pendant tant d'années
a abouti à des excès ce constat
s'applique autant à l'hôpital où la T2A
représente la moitié des financements
qu'au secteur privé où ça paraît
beaucoup plus élevé le texte amorce une
évolution en la matière mais y
conviendra sans doute que les PLF PLFSS
prochain se montre plus audacieux en
prolongeant et en amplifiant ses
réformes nous savons que le salue de
notre système de santé dans un contexte
où sa pérénité requiert une nécessaire
maîtrise des comptes publics passe en
priorité par la chasse aux rentes aux
revenus facile pour se concentrer sur ce
qui sert réellement à la santé des
Français pour mieux payer la
consultation du généraliste pour mieux
les payer les salaires à l'hôpital pour
mieux équiper les établissements de
toutes sortes de manière à mieux prendre
en charge la santé des Français la
responsabilité qui est la notôtre en
tant que législateur est ainsi de
préserver ses services publics et tous
les opérateurs du soin cette
responsabilité se traduit par le
nécessaire équilibre budgétaire que nous
devons poursuivre et cette deuxème
partie du texte qui porte sur les
recettes pour 2024 est porteuse de ces
réformes en particulier dans la lutte
contre la fraude sociale notamment la
lutte contre les arrêts maladies
injustifiées le texte que nous propose
le gouvernement enrichi par les
propositions des parlementaires
permettrait permettra de mettre en œuvre
des mesures très attendues notamment et
je veux les citer la réforme de
l'assiette de cotisation et les
contributions sociales des travailleurs
indépendants la Gel du bandeau famille
sur les salaires de 2,5 à 3,5 SMIC
proposition issue d'ailleurs d'un
rapport parlementaire transpartisan ou
enfin la création d'une nouvelle
sanction pénale d'incitation publique à
la fraude sociale dans l'impossibilité
de mener des débat raisonné pour finir
ces discussions la voix de la
responsabilité sera toujours celle de ce
gouvernement et de sa majorité à
laquelle nous appartenons et donc
d'engager le 493 en conclusion madame la
Première ministre sachez que le groupe
Horizon est apparenté vous renouvelle
tout son soutien et ne votera bien sûr
pas ces deux motions de
censure je vous
remercie la parole est à monsieur
Sébastien PAVI pour le groupe écologiste
pour une durée de 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre messieurs dames les
ministres chers
collègues aujourd'hui nous avons
failli nous avons failli à notre mission
de doter notre pays d'un budget à la
hauteur des besoins de celles et ceux
qui nous ont élu nos instances de
gouvernance ont failliis en ayant
recours au 493 pour la 14e fois là sur
le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale vous avez failli à
votre mission celle de discuter des
recettes pour 2024 et dotter de recettes
suffisantes notre sécurité sociale pour
couvrir les besoins de soins et
d'accompagnement cela est non seulement
profondément désolant mais ce n'est
encore moins drôle car oui en dépit de
vos bavardages de vos rir qui peuvent
paraître méprisants lors de la loocution
la semaine dernière profondément
empreinte de clairevoyance et de sagesse
de mon collègue monsieur leayic ce dédin
manifeste de nos institutions n'a rien
de drôle le recours au 493 et le coûp
systématique qu'il représente pour la
démocratie est profondément dangereux
car il fait naître un sentiment
d'injustice chez nos concitoyens et nos
concitoyennes le mouvement inédit des
gilets jaunes a pointé du doigt
l'abandon d'une partie de la population
qui se sent au périphérie de la
démocratie la crise du coronavirus
laisse encore des traces dans son impact
intime financier et social qu'il a eu
sur la population la plus vulnérable
nous avons connu cet été la plus grave
crise sociale dans les quartiers
populaires dont la demande de justice et
d'égalité est restée insuffisante alors
que depuis 6 ans nous faisons face à une
crise sociale économique et écologique
sans précédent qui frappe toutes les
couches de notre société nous devrions
opérer un véritable choc démocratique
loin du passage en force nous devrions
réinventer écouter et réellement
composer avec avec par exemple les
conventions citoyennes dont vous avez
moqué les rendus malgré un rejet massif
des millions de personnes dans la rue et
des mobilisations historiques contre la
réforme des retraites votre gouvernement
est tombé dans l'obsession d'avoir
raison seul et de gouverner seul il
refuse toute contradiction jusqu'à en
limoger le président du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites cette
obstination est aujourd'hui directement
responsable d'un taux jamais atteint
avant d'abstention et la banalisation
des 493 encourage le dégoût et le rejet
massif de nos institutions qui iront
irrémédiablement se répercuter vers
l'extrême droite de cette hémicycle la
banalisation des 493 qui est un outil
certes constitutionnel mais éminemment
brutal montre les limites d'un système
présidentialiste dépassé vous arguerez
qu'il y a trop d'amendements que
l'opposition vous chahute mais madame la
Première ministre quand les
parlementaires savent qu'ils ne pourront
ni s'exprimer ni défendre leur position
en séance publique comment peut-on on
les blâmer de vouloir le faire en
commission c'est cela aussi le 493 c'est
celui qui réduit le droit d'amendement
des parlementaires à l'exercice d'un
temps de parole en commission c'est
celui qui par sa brutalité empêche le
débat ces discussions ont leurs
inconvénients le silence en a davantage
oui gloire au pays où l'on parle honte
au pays où l' se tait c'est ainsi que
répondait clémenau au général Boulanger
le 4 juin 1888 à la Chambre des députés
au Parlement avant de voter la loi on la
discute désormais au Parlement on
discute plus on ne vote plus non plus
face à cette mascarade on pourrait vous
trouver l'excuse d'une 5e République qui
disfonctionne faute de fait de fait
majoritaire mais ce serait ignoré dans
cette grande pièce de théâtre le rôle
pivot des républicains car vous avez au
fond bel et bien une majorité une
majorité caché non assumé mais une
majorité car si LR était bel et bien
dans l'opposition alors il voterait
cette motion de censure cette stratégie
stratégie gagnante sur la droite de cet
hémicycle où vous pouvez voter nos
amendements de suppression jouant à
l'opposition mais qui ne manque pas de
gonfler vos rangs pour faire passer
l'ensemble de vos textes de casse
sociale les 493 sont prévisibles à leur
prêt nos votes aussi cette situation
dramatique symbole d'une démocratie
malade et vidée de son sens crée un
précédent dans l'histoire de notre 5e
République ce boulevard que vous ouvrez
pleinement au rassemblement national
crée un précédent et vous en êtes
pleinement responsable car malgré leur
motion de censure sans aucun projet si
ce n'est la haine le rassemblement
national s'accommode très bien de cette
usage constitutionnel puisque le
rassemblement national lui aussi se sert
de la démocratie comme une marche-pied
pour mieux s'en détourner ensuite quelle
image notre institution renvoie-t-elle
au peuple alors que des députés de votre
majorité ne font même plus semblant
abandonnant et désertent les rang de
l'hémicycle et des commissions à quoi
les Françaises et les Français qui nous
ont donné leur confiance doivent-ils
s'attendre pour le budget de l'année
prochaine comment débattre dans des
conditions sérieuses du budget que nous
souhaitons donner à la nation nous avons
des députés élus don leur premier rôle
est celui de voter des lois qui ne font
même plus semblant de respecter leur
engagement comment ne pas s'étonner que
le peuple n'y voit plus aucune bonne
raison de voter par notre soutien à
cette motion de censure présentée par la
France insoumise nous souhaitons vous
rappeler cette chose fondamentale vous
montrer à nouveau aujourd'hui que notre
démocratie est dans une impasse et que
la 5e République montre ses limites vous
avez justifié l'usage du 493 la semaine
dernière en affirmant que vous n'aviez
pas réussi à trouver des points d'accord
mais l'Assemblée nationale s'était bel
et bien accordée en séance pour rejeter
votre petite rectification financière
pour 2023 et sans nul doute comme en
commission celle pour 2024 nous ne
serions dès lors plus étonnés que vous
balayez également ce rejet dans la
version finale du texte si nous
différions Sudant les motifs de ce rejet
cela nous oblige d'autant plus madame la
Première ministre à trouver un chemin
favorable un chemin vers le respect de
notre institution du pluralisme et de la
réconciliation face à une société plus
que jamais divisée mais jamais celui de
l'abandon comme vous le fait aujourd'hui
nous assistons à un simulacre de
démocratie mis en musique dans le
théâtre d'un hémicycle vide vide de ses
rangs vide de son peuple vide de sa
démocratie alors non madame la Première
ministre cela n'a rien de drôle alors
que Sanofi qui a perçu plus de 1,5
milliards de crédits d'impôt recherche
en 10 ans n'est non seulement pas
parvenu à trouver un vaccin à temps mais
annoncé la semaine dernière se séparer
de son pôle de santé grand public alors
que ses dividendes sont en hausse pour
la 29e année consécutive et quelle
temporalité alors que cet abandon qui
met en péril l'approvisionnement des
médicaments essentiels intervient 2
jours seulement après votre coup de
force sur le budget de la Sécurité
sociale ce budget n'est pas la hauteur
pour sortir de l'asphixie permanente nos
hôpitaux et pour garantir une vie
décente et digne aux personnes en perte
d'autonomie il n'est pas à la hauteur
alors que plus de 4,8 millions de foyers
en précarité énergétique vont devoir à
nouveau cet hiver affronter l'explosion
des fractures énergétiques il n'est pas
à la hauteur pour garantir à chacun et à
chacune l'accès à un logement salubre à
une alimentation de qualité et à des
soins intégralement pris en charge nous
le répéterons sans relarche gouverner
c'est prévoir et cela est incompatible
avec un logiciel productiviste qui ne
mise que sur la réduction des dépenses
publiques nous devons tirer les leçons
de la crise du coronavirus et interroger
le modèle de développement dans lequel
s'est engagé notre monde depuis des
décennies la santé n'a pas de prix notre
État providence ne sont pas de coût ou
de charg mais des biens précieux ces
paroles ce sont pas les nôtres mais
celles du président de la République
déclaré il y a maintenant 2 ans et demi
nous ne pouvons que constater que ces
promesses n'ont aujourd'hui pas été
traduites dans ce budget car ce budget
ne sera jamais à la hauteur dès lors que
votre obsession pour un ou deux points
de croissance passera systématiquement
devant l'objectif de vivre dignement sur
une planète respirable car investir
massivement dans la prévention à tous
les niveaux dans une démarche de pleine
santé est l'unique garantie pour pouvoir
améliorer le bien-être et la santé de la
population nous avons toutes et tous
porté un ruban d'Octobre rose pour
lutter contre le cancer du sein mais où
sont dans ce budget les mesures pour
lutter à la racine du mal contre les
facteurs environnementaux qui augmente
les risques de développer un cancer du
sein où est l'argent pour lutter
efficacement contre la pollution de
l'air où est l'argent pour lutter contre
les pesticides et les polluants éternels
contre le tabac la malbouffe la
sédentarité pas une seule mesure pour
favoriser la santé environnementale et
donc la baisse des cas de cancer du sein
aujourd'hui par cette Nim 493 vous
rejetez les prérogatives de ce Parlement
pour voter un budget ambitieux contre la
prévalence des maladies chroniques ces
responsabilité vous incombe pourtant
d'avoir le courage d'aller chercher
l'argent là où il est pour transformer
en profondeur notre société alors non
madame la ministre la première ministre
cela n'a rien de drôle et votre majorité
relative et friable vous confère
davantage le devoir de dialoguer que le
droit de maîtriser notre représentation
nationale alors face au piétinement de
la voix des Françaises et des Français
nous appelons un véritable choc de
démocratie pour que notre institution
puisse enfin proposer une réponse à la
hauteur face aux fractures sociales et à
la crise que nous
traversons je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
pour le groupe de la Gauche démocrate et
républicaine pour une durée de 10
minutes madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers et chers
collègues
ma chère maman merci pour l'article que
tu m'as envoyé c'est vrai au moment où
je t'écris la guerre continue de
déferler provoquant la mort de femmes
d'hommes d'enfant détruisant les maisons
les routes ou les oliviers seant la
désolation plongeant l'humanité dans un
terrible cauchemar je sais bien que
cette situation t'inquiète et te révolte
et je pleure avec toi toutes les
victimes et les prisonniers
ma préoccupation la plus vive est que se
déploie une action politique intense
pour arrêter le massacre en finir avec
le dénis du droit international et du
droit des peuples stopper la
colonisation et construire la paix la
justice et la
paix cette volonté doit pouvoir se faire
entendre dans les villes de notre
pays pourtant il faut quand même
continuer à s'occuper des affaires plus
ordinaires et des choix politiques de
notre pays pour l'année qui vient je
dois monter demain à la tribune de
l'Assemblée nationale pour une motion
dite de censure contre le gouvernement
afin de contester le budget de la
Sécurité sociale dont on nous explique
que c'est le meilleur budget de tous les
temps de toute l'Europe de tout
l'univers visible et invisible ça c'est
moi qui
l'ajoute je dois t'avouer que je ne sais
plus bien comment leur dire ce que je
ressens tu n'imagines pas à quel point
il se trouve formidable il voudrait sans
doute que nous le reconnaissions et que
nous le leur disions ah si votre ramage
se rapportait à votre votre plumage mais
en fait nous sommes en désaccord si
c'est possible ne t'inquiète pas je
répondrai dans la foulé au message des
cousins chers cousins la description que
vous me faites de votre quotidien est en
effet très
préoccupante je partage votre colère et
celle de votre syndicat l'hôpital
s'enfonce dans la crise et on continue
l'objectif national de dép d'assurance
maladie est annoncée à 3,2 %
c'est-à-dire une augmentation inférieure
à celle de l'année dernière qui était en
dessous de l'inflation et inférieure à
l'augmentation naturelle estimée aux
alentours de 4,5 %. alors même que ces
dernières années le budget ordinaire a
déjà été beaucoup compressé et de sur
croi la tendance que veut nous faire
valider pour les années qui viennent est
une compression encore plus forte c'est
insensé alors que les personnels tirent
la sonnette d'alarme il faudrait donner
de l'air à l'hôpital et plus largement à
notre notre système de santé et
permettre à ces actrices et acteurs de
se projeter dans un nouvel élan quant
aux rémunération à la reconnaissance du
travail et des métiers à la
déprécarisation elles sont décisives
pour l'avenir vous pouvez compter sur
moi pour porter ces messages car il y a
un désaccord fondamental notamment sur
le choix d'un tel niveau d'exonération
de cotisation sociale qui finit par les
délégitimer et qui conduit à
sous-financer la sécurité sociale alors
que nous avons besoin de socialiser ses
ressources des ressources pour nous
protéger mutuellement il faut faire face
aux besoins de santé cette année 2,5
milliards d'euros d'exonération ne
seront pas compensé et en plus ils vont
piquer dans les cotisations des
retraites complémentaires ils vont
piquer dans la caisse de l'Unedic et ils
trouvent ça normal la dette public covid
a été transféré sur les épaules de la
sécurité sociale un bien mauvais calcul
social et financier l'an dernier j'avais
réussi à faire adopter un amendement
record à 18 milliards d'euros qui
contestait ce choix le gouvernement dit
avoir tout fait pour trouver des points
d'accord bien sûr il y a des choses sur
lesquelles on peut être d'accord et tant
mieux c'est le cas sur la prévention
contre le papillom virirus ou sur les
préservatifs gratuits qui sont les deux
nouveautés mises en avant mais ça ne
fait pas une politique sanitaire et
sociale à la hauteur on peut aussi
remarquer que le gouvernement propose
enfin des mesures pour venir au secours
du don du sang cela semble néanmoins
bien insuffisant pour faire face aux
difficultés et un amendement de dernière
minute semble aller en sens inverse sur
les médicaments issus du plasma alors
même que c'est un enjeu éthtique et
sanitaire décisif la suppression de la
tarification à l'activité annoncée se
traduira seulement par une faible
diminution et je sais que vous y êtes
sensible aucun effort visible n'est
programmé pour l'instant pour les soins
palliatifs et leur déploiement alors que
150000 personnes qui pourraient y
prétendre en son privé chaque année et
ça fait 20 ans que ça dure le dispositif
MSI qui est un échec avéré n'est pas
remis en question et il y a parfois plus
d'un an d'attente pour avoir un
rendez-vous dans un centre
médico-psychologique dans une une
société angoissée et fracturée il aurait
fallu des mesures fortes pour la santé
mentale de façon plus générale je suis
inquiet des phénomènes de
financiarisation qui se développe dans
le monde de la santé et face auxquel il
faudrait déployer une action vigoureuse
et je ne crois pas que les modifications
apporter à la contribution des
entreprises du médicament aille dans ce
sens un pôle public de production et de
recherche pour le médicament devient un
besoin criant je ne vous parle même pas
du droit à l'autonomie pour lequel la
volonté politique nécessaire est
toujours repoussée plus loin il y a
aussi besoin d'accélérer sur la
prévention c'est-à-dire sur les
changements de nos modes de vie de
production de consommation et de se
donner de meilleurs outils je pense à la
santé au travail la seule chose que le
gouvernement trouve à faire c'est de
donner la main au médecin diligeanté par
l'employeur pour contrôler les arrêts de
travail en chantant ainsi la sécurité
sociale et son médecin conseil objectif
300 millions d'économies alors même que
les causes des arrêts maladiie ne sont
pas interrogés et encore nous avons
réussi à faire supprimer une nouvelle
disposition qui veut venit réformer de
manière complètement injuste la faute
inexcusable de l'employeur mais en fait
si on veut résumer c'est toujours les
mêmes qui trinquent avec sans doute une
augmentation à la clé des franchises à
venir sans compter que ce budget est le
premier à mettre en œuvre cette réforme
des retraites qui n'en finit pas de ne
pas passer voilà je vais désormais
essayer d'écrire mon intervention pour
cette motion de censure bien mérité je
n'avais pas encore de déguisement pour
Halloween mais un déguisement de
paillasson non merci
vous m'interrogez sur le sens de cette
nouvelle motion de censure elle est
nécessaire pour marquer notre refus non
seulement de ce budget de la Sécurité
sociale qui sonne creux et qui n'est
absolument pas à la hauteur des besoins
et qui nous est imposé par 493 elle est
aussi indispensable pour marquer au
début des débats budgétaires notre refus
résolu de l'abaissement du Parlement
dans une République où le gouvernement
tient désormais sa légitimité tout
entière du président qui est à peu près
ministre de tout en effet alors que le
débat sur les recettes n'avait même pas
commencé madame la Première ministre est
monté à la tribune avec un grand sourire
pour nous expliquer qu'elle se passerait
de notre avis et les députés de la Major
de la majorité la majorité minoritaire
se sont levés pour applaudir je ne
comprends pas comment on peut applaudir
un 493 s résoudre à la limite mais
l'applaudir ça me dépasse le 493 est un
aveu d'échec pour ceux qui le
déclenchent madame la Première ministre
renvoie la responsabilité sur les
méchantes oppositions au gentils
gouvernement responsables et l'argument
employé pour clore le débat la semaine
dernière après avoir procédé de la même
façon sur le budget de l'État consistait
à expliquer qu'il n'y a pas
d'alternative puisque les oppositions ne
sont pas d'accord entre elles je dois
avouer que c'est un progrès déjà sur
l'année précédente puisqu'ils avaient
joué un petit jeu dangereux en pointant
du doigt une alliance imaginaire et à
nos yeux infamante mais il s'agit
toujours de se défausser de ses
responsabilités or l'absence de majorité
absolu devrait obliger plus encore le
gouvernement à des efforts qu'il se
dispense désormais de faire avec une
forme de désinvolture non seulement il
n'a pas véritablement fait évoluer le
texte sur les points de désaccord mais
en plus il a rajouté une poignée
d'amendements discutaes qui n'ont pas
été examiné en commission à l'Assemblée
je m'efforce de faire entendre des
aspirations et des réalités que le
gouvernement laisse dans l'ombre je
m'efforce de faire raisonner une autre
voie une autre vision et de rendre
crédiible et possible d'autres choix une
alternative le 493 utilisé de cette
façon nouvelle veut empêcher cela en
mettant fin au débat avant même qu'il
nit commencé lorsqu'il est utilisé de la
sorte il signe une dérobade complète il
va matérialiser un exercice et une
conception du pouvoir qui ne laisse même
pas au Parlement l'espace de discuter le
débat sur la santé la protection sociale
une fois par an et pourtant un
rendez-vous essentiel une société où le
par Parlement ne débat plus est une
société où la démocratie ne va pas bien
chers et chers collègues pardon de vous
avoir fait partager mon courrier mais je
crois qu'il permettra d'expliquer ici et
au-delà pourquoi les députés communistes
et ultramarin du groupe de la Gauche
démocrate et républicaine voteront la
censure du gouvernement pour son mauvais
budget de la Sécurité sociale pour ces
mauvaises manières à l'égard du
Parlement pour l'ensemble de son œuvre
je vous remerci
la parole est à Monsieur Stéphane
Lenormand pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre mer et territoire pour
une durée de 10 minutes
maximum bien madame la présidente madame
la Première ministre mesdames Messieurs
les les ministres chers collègues je ne
me livrerai pas à la comptabilité des
493 13 14 bientôt 15 pas plus que je ne
mentionnerai le dépôt pavlovien des
motion de censure les membres de mon
groupe ont déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
à cette tribune le 493 affaiblit la
pratique démocratique et il affaiblit le
gouvernement qui recours mais je crois
aussi que l'accumulation des échecs des
motion de censure et cet après-midi on
rajoutera sans doute un tant à banaliser
le recours à cette procédure d'exception
ce faisant nous sommes dans une sorte de
bras de fer stérile qui ne tient que
finalement par un équilibre de menac et
de pression s'agissant des 493 vous
aviez annoncé à mot peine couvert qu'il
deviendrait la norme des textes
budgétaires néanmoins au-delà de leur
caractère désormais automatique je ne
peux que regretter que vous l'ayez
dégainé sitôt vous en avez parfaitement
le droit la Constitution vous permet un
recours illimité sur les textes
budgétaires cela nous le savons tous né
moins nous voyons que cette pratique du
pouvoir a des effets néfastes sur nos
institutions elle donne le sentiment que
ce que nous votons ici n'a pas
d'importance et que notre rôle de
représentant élu démocratiquement est
insignifiant et vous dérange presque je
crois pour ma part que si les
oppositions ne sont pas écouté dans un
cadre institutionnel démocratique nous
prenons le risque qu'ell s'exprime plus
violemment en dehors de ce cadre
pourtant nous avons joué le jeu de la
concertation des députés de mon groupe
Paul André Colombani Laurent panifous
ont participé à votre ébouche de
concertation sur les comptes de Ségure
et au final je m'interroge à haute voix
madame la ministre madame la Première
ministre pardon à quoi cette
concertation a-t-elle servi a-t-elle
permis une coconstruction ce mot que
l'on entend si souvent qui se concrétise
si rarement clairement non nous avons
fait des propositions pour l'hôpital
pour le grand âge pour de nouveaux
financements pour une Nou nouvelle
organisation tout ou presque a été
balayé ces concertations sont-elles la
traduction d'une maintendue loyalement
slogan si cher à notre président ou
est-ce juste pour faire semblant
pourtant la situation budgétaire de
notre système de sécurité sociale
devrait nous conduire en responsabilité
à essayer de dépasser nos clivages pour
le bien commun car la sécurité sociale
c'est notre bien commun cette situation
est d'autant plus inquiétante que
derrière cet acronyme un peu barbare du
PLFSS se joue une partie de la vie de
nos C citoyens tous nous disent leur
inquiétude sur les fermetur des services
d'urgence mes collègues Paul maollac et
Christophe nagelen vous ont interpellé
ces dernières semaines sur la réalité
vécue dans leur territoire beaucoup nous
disent leur difficulté à trouver un
médecin traitant vous me répondrez
numérus apertus mais dans combien de
temps aurons-nous des effets et et en
attendant comment empêcher que les
déserts médicaux s'étendent tous aussi
nous ont ont été profondément choqués
par les scandales révélé ces dernières
années dans les épades et nous sommes de
trouver des solutions celles qui nous
sont proposées sont clairement
insuffisante voilà quelques défis qui
nous font face comment les affronter
dans le contexte actuel les indicateurs
doivent nous alerter en 2023 vous
tabliez sur un déficit plus élevé que
prévu à hauteur de 8 8 milliards d'euros
toute branche confondu contre 6,8
milliards dans la précédente loi de
finance de la sécurité sociale pour 2024
le déficit se creuserait encore à 11,2
milliards les branches maladies et
vieillesse connaissent les déficites les
plus importants je note d'ailleurs qu'en
2024 le coût de la réforme des retraites
sera de 200 millions d'euros vous mettez
en avant une politique d'économie pour
un montant de 3,5 milliards dans le
texte initial mais cela n'empêche pas le
déficit de se creuser dans le même en
même temps il y a un consensus pour
considérer que la hausse de l'endarme
inscrite dans ce PLFSS est insuffisante
pour faire face à l'inflation la hausse
des coûts affecte aussi le
fonctionnement et les projets
d'investissement et cela renforce notre
crainte de voir un hôpital à de vitesse
en d'autres termes les hôpitaux nous
disent qu'il leur manque entre 1,5 et 2
milliards d'euros pour fonctionner de
manière suffisante vous avez rejeté nos
amendements de relèvement de landendam
et nous le regrettons vous avez
récemment indié un réexamen d'ici la fin
de l'année de la situation financière
des hôpitaux nous serons très attentifs
à vos annonces j'attire aussi votre
attention sur un autre problème de
financement propre au territoire
insulaire et d'outr mè pour compenser
ces surcoutts structurels nous demandons
une revalorisation des coefficients
géographique et leur réévaluation
annuelle au-delà que nous disent les
établissements de santé qu'il manque de
visibilité alors pourquoi ne pas leur en
donner une pour une période de 5 ans
vous pourriez reprendre cette
proposition dans le cadre de la réforme
à venir du financement des hôpitaux à ce
sujet nous vous redisons notre souhait
d'accélération de la réforme de la
tarification à l'acte au profit d'une
tarification basé notamment sur les
besoins de santé mais ceci ne sera pas
suffisant car les mots des hôpitaux sont
plus profonds certains praticiens nous
disent avoir l'impression d'une course
effrainée à la rentabilité d'autres nous
alertent sur la complexité du
fonctionnement du poids de la
suradministration l'hôpital a besoin
d'une grande réforme structurelle avec
un choc de décentralisation je vais
aussi m'attarder sur une autre grande
réforme qui est sans cesse repousser
Rogier nous souhaitions une grande loi
sur le grand âge nous devrons nous cont
nous contenter de la petite proposition
de loi bienveillir le président de la
République avait d'ailleurs promis le
recrutement de 50000 personnel
supplémentaire dans les épas dans 5 ans
nous sommes loin du compte 3000 ont été
promis en 2023 combien ont été
réellement créés 6000 leçons 2024 à ce
rythme la trajectoire ne sera pas tenue
plus largement nous regr l'absence de
financement dédié à la branche autonomie
plus de 3 ans après sa création le
transfert d'une fraction de CSG prévue
pour 2024 ne représentera que 2,6
milliards ce sera insuffisant là encore
nous avons fait un certain nombre de
propositions de financement de création
de 6000 postes supplémentaires en 20
nous continuons à défendre deux
améliorations primordiales la création
d'une loi de programmation qui a été
adoptée en commission ainsi qu'une
expérimentation d'un forfait fusionné
des volets soins et dépendances dans les
éepades dans les départements
candidats enfin nous ne pouvons plus
reporter le débat sur le financement de
notre système de protection sociale nous
nous interrogeons sur la pertinence de
certaines exonérations de cotisation
social sur les salaires au-dessus de 2,5
SMIC nous avions fait une proposition
qui permettait une économie d' 1,6
milliard d'euros d'autres députés de
votre majorité ont fait des propositions
qui différaent des nôes mais sur
lesquelles une majorité a été trouvée en
quelques mots elle visait à supprimer
certains allègements sur les salaires
compris entre 2 et 3,5 SMIC ont
contreparti d'un coup de pouce salarial
sur les bas salaires en cette période de
forte inflation qui touche les classes
populaires cela n'était pas dénué
d'intérêt rien de tout cela ne figure
dans le texte que vous nous proposez au
moment de faire le bilan je relève
néanmoins certaines mesures positives
notamment s'agissant du renforcement du
volet prévention je pense à la
vaccination du papilloma virus en
collège à l'accès gratuit au
préservatifs aux protections
menstruelles réutilisable je note aussi
quelques menus amélioration en faveur
des TR travailleurs indépendant
notamment par la reprise d' amendement
de notre collègue Christophe nagelin ces
avancées demeurent modestes mais la
principale raison qui nous poussera à ne
pas voter cette motion de centure vient
de votre abandon de deux mesures
particulièrement injustes la première
concerne votre projet d'augmenter la
franchise sur les médicaments et la
participation forfaitaire pour les
consultations cette disposition ne
figurait pas dans le texte initial mais
était clairement prévu vous avez reculé
mais je note que vous semblez ne pas
avoir abandonné cette idée comme l'a
indiqué le ministre ministre Thomas
casenov sur France interre pourriez-vous
d'ailleurs nous éclairer sur l'état des
négociations sur cette question dernier
point d'opposition votre volonté de
panctionner la girirarco au nom de notre
attachement au paritarisme qui est le
cœur de notre modèle social nous avons
dit notre résolution à lutter contre
cette pensction à hauteur de 1 milliard
d'euros avec laquelle vous vouliez
financer le déficit du régime général
des retraites les partenaires sociaux
ont bien gérer la girarcou nous estimons
que le gouvernement n'a pas à toucher à
ses réserves comme sur les franchises
vous vous avez reculé mais semblait
n'avoir pas renoncé là encore nous vous
demandons des éclaircissements sur vos
intentions mais sachez que sur cette
question notre détermination est totale
pour conclure la crise économique qui
perdure un peu partout dans le monde et
la situation de la géopolitique
particulièrement tragique ces derniers
temps voire ces dernières heures ne nous
permett pas d'avoir le choix et nous
pousse à chercher un compromis politique
responsable seulement pour nous ne pas
voter cette motion de censure ne
signifie surtout pas vouloir vous donner
notre confiance car celle-ci est
particulièrement ébranlée ou encore vous
encourager à poursuivre cette course
infernale au 493 notre volonté de vous
mettre en garde les dérives les
manquements dans un pays démocratique et
l'histoire la démontrer voi toujours
leur fin plus tôt que plus tard et
n'oubliez pas que c'est avec le peuple
que vous devez construire ces projets et
le peuple c'est nous tous ici dans cet
hémicycle je vous
remercie je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Fanta verérité
pour le groupe renaissance pour une
durée de 50 minutes
[Applaudissements]
maximum
merci
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la rapporteur générale chers
collègues au moment de prendre la parole
devant vous à l'occasion de l'examen de
la motion de censure déposée par
certains membres de laanupes sur la
deuxème partie du PLFSS 2024 j'ai décidé
de ne pas vous dire bien que la
rapporteur générale l' rappelé que le
PLFSS c'est
643 milliards d'euros 643 milliards
d'euros soit 1/3 de notre richesse
nationale pour protéger nos
concitoyens j'ai décidé de ne pas vous
dire non plus que l'ONDAM est en hausse
constante avec plus de 3,2 % prévu en
2024 sur la base d'un Nam 2023 rectifié
à plus 4 4,8 % il vous plaît de
l'occulter mais il s'agit d'une
augmentation belle et bien supérieure à
l'inflation prévu pour l'année
prochaine je ne vous dirai pas que cela
correspond à 54 milliards d'euros de
plus comparé à il y a 5 ans soit C fois
plus d'augmentation que sous le dernier
quinquena de gauche et 2 et demi de plus
que sous le dernier quinquena de droite
et oui
je ne vous dirai pas que ce PLFSS vise
encore et toujours la prévention à tous
les étages du système de santé la
prévention avec la vaccination contre le
papilloma virus en milieu scolaire pour
l'ensemble d'une classe d'âge ceci dans
le but de rattraper un taux de
couverture vaccinale volontaire tandis
que 6400 nouveaux cas de cancers par an
sont attribués au
HPV la prévention en matière de santé
sexuelle et reproductive des jeunes en
faisant le choix d'un accès gratuit au
préservatif en pharmacie pour tous les
moins de 26 ans ces derniers
représentant le public le plus concerné
par les grossesses non désirées et les
infections sexuellement transmissible
ou encore la prévention contre la
précarité menstruelle qui touche 44 %
des 18 24 ans les privants d'utiliser
donc des serviettes de protection
hygiénique ou de différer leur
renouvellement régulier ce qui peut
affecter leur santé notamment au travers
du choc toxique ce PLFSS 2024 permettra
un remboursement des protections
hygiéniques réutilisables pour les
jeunes femmes de moins de 26 ans ainsi
que pour toutes les bénéficiaires de la
complémentaire santé solidaire sans
limite
d'âge je ne vous dirai pas non plus que
ce PLFSS propose un investissement
ambitieux dans le système de santé pour
un fonctionnement modernisé au service
d'un meilleur accès aux soins comment et
bien 20 ans après la tarification à
l'activité il est nécessaire d'adapter
notre système de financement aux
nouveaux enjeux de santé
publique et vous savez quoi le PLFSS le
prévoit avec un objectif de réduction de
la part des financements issus de la T2A
pour évoluer vers un modèle de
financement mixte qui valorise
différemment les activités des
établissements selon leur caractéris
renforcer l'attractivité méti des
métiers dans les établissements de santé
c'est également prévu monsieur Bazin
dans les accords salariaux de
revalorisation dans un contexte
d'inflation avec la majoration des
gardes des personnels médicaux de 50 %
avec un nouveau système de rémunération
du personnel non médical de nuit avec
une majoration du travail de nuit de 25
% avec une rémunération des dimanches et
des jours fériers travaillés majoré de
l'ordre de 20
%. ce PLFSS c'est aussi une volonté
celle de rénover de renforcer la filière
palliative celle de mieux diffuser les
prises en charge innovantes en
facilitant l'inscription dans le droit
commun des expérimentations
organisationnelles qui ont fait leur
preuve et enfin de faciliter les soins
en élargissant les champs de coopération
et les compétences des pharmaciens
aujourd'hui par exemple 3 millions de
consultations médicales par an
concernent les cistites simples et 6
millions des angines désormaet pour
limiter les délais d'attente et éviter
l'automédicamentation les pharmaciens
pourront dispenser sans ordonnance
certains médicaments à prescription
médicale obligatoire dont les
antibiotiques après réalisation d'un
test rapide d'orientation diagnostique
pour les cystides simples et les engines
en voilà encore une avancé de ce PLFSS
2024 ce
PLFSS ne vous en déplaise vise à mieux
articuler la complémentaire santé
solidaire avec les minemas sociaux en
proposant d'étendre son attribution
simplifiée à la plupart des allocataires
de laallocation adulte handicapés de
laallocation supplémentaire d'invalidité
de laallocation de solidarité spécifique
et de laallocation du contrat
d'engagement jeune dorénavant ces
assurés bénéficieront d' une présomption
de droit à la C2S avec une participation
financière qui contribuera à accroître
leur recours au dispositifs et
améliorera leur accès aux soins vous
l'aurez compris je ne vais pas vous dire
que le PLFSS 2024 vise à garantir
l'accès des Français aux médicaments du
quotidien et aux produits de santé
innovants ceci notamment via des mesures
qui consiste à diminuer l'usage
d'antibiotique pour limiter les ruptures
d'approvisionnement et l'antibiorésist
ance ou encore qu' a vocation à adapter
l'offre aux évolutions démographiques et
à décliner les engagements de la
Conférence nationale du
handicap sur la partie 2 qui nous
concerne plus précisément aujourd'hui je
ne vous diraai pas non plus que le
déficit de la Sécurité sociale est
estimé à 11,2 milliards en 2024 que les
comptes sont plombés par la hausse des
dépenses de l'assurance maladie et que
nous avons le devoir de maîtriser ce
déficit public ceci se traduit dans ce
PLFSS par une lutte forte et résolue
contre la fraude sociale qui met en
péril notre système car elle représente
une atteinte à l'équité et à la justice
sociale et Auer le financement des
prestations et services
essentiels seront donc mis en place de
nouveaux outils comme le renforcement
des obligations des plateformes
numériques à garantir le paiement des
cotisations d par ses utilisateurs mais
aussi la pression de la prise en charge
des cotisations sociales sur les revenus
qui auront été obtenus de façon
frauduleuse par des professionnels de
santé peu
scrupuleux non je ne vous le dirai pas
parce qu'en réalité vous le savez déjà
je ne vous dirai pas tout cela puisque
quoi que contienne ou qu'aurait pu
contenir ce texte vos postures sont
tellement ancrées et la mécanique
tellement conditionnée vos prises de
parole robotisé que votre action sera la
même une opposition un vote contre suivi
d'une motion de censure et oui nous n
sommes plus très surpris on a
malheureusement pris
l'habitude en revanche ce que j'ai à
vous dire c'est que choisir le mot
minoritaire dans votre texte minoritaire
parmi tous les mots existant dans la
langue française pour qualifier le
projet de financement de la sécurité
sociale 2020 24 c'est tellement hors
seul c'est tellement
petit ce que j'ai à vous dire c'est
qu'écrire que vous avez ouvrer les
guillemets contraint le gouvernement à
reculer sur la hausse des franchises
médicales alors qu'il n'en a jamais été
question dans le texte ou sur le
soi-disant ponction argique Arco au-delà
de vous donner plus de pouvoir que vous
n'en avez cela montre à quel point votre
parole est mensongère s'il vous plaît ce
que j'ai à vous dire c'est qu' écrire
dans une motion de censure que plus d'un
Français sur trois a déjà renoncé à des
soins ou équipements médicaux et dans le
même temps s'opposer à un texte qui
prévoit d'élargir la C2S aux
bénéficiaaires de certains minimas
sociaux au-delà de témoigner du niveau
de votre opposition systématique cela
montre à quel point votre parole n'est
que
démagogie ce que j'ai à vous dire enfin
c'est qu'écrire que la suppression de
l'article 39 est un tour tour de force
de votre part alors que l'ensemble des
commissaires aux affaires sociales
étaient d'accord pour respecter la
volonté gouvernementale de rouvrir des
discussion avec les partenaires sociaux
sur l'évolution du régime
d'indemnisation
ATMP et bien au-delà de mettre en
lumière la désinformation dont vous usez
régulièrement et qui de est est débonqué
par les uns et par les autres cela
montre à quel point votre parole est
tragiqueomique si les Français savaient
si seulement ils savaient
remarquer ils sont de moins en moins
duple et nous avons pu le voir dans un
épisode récent malheureux il commence à
constater à quel point ils se sont fait
instrumentaliser par vos villes
manœuvres et votre autre
cuidance vous
plaît un peu de respect c'est mutuel on
peut essayer de s'écouter également
monsieur le député comme le disait le
ministre Aurélien Rousseau oui le
système de santé souffre oui certains
territoires et certains professionnels
sont en grande difficulté oui c'est une
bataille quotidienne que nous devons
mener pour inventer des solutions pour
redonner des moyens et du sens aux
acteurs de la santé mais le tableau noir
dressé par certains est profondément
injuste je dirais même plus car vous
êtes bien des choses mais vous n'êtes
pas naïf ce tableau noir est savamment
orchestré dans un but qui est tout sauf
celui de servir le collectif car notre
système de santé aussi fragile qu'il
soit est un système de santé magnifique
et que faire reculer sa fragilité est la
seule feuille de route du ministre et
cela doit être également la nôtre mais
comme ce dernier l'a dit cette feuille
de route impose de la
lucidité alors avec il alors avec des il
faut que vous devez on ne fait que
donner des leçons et et vous brillez
dans ce rôle être réaliste et
responsable c'est ce qui vous est
demandé c'est ce qui nous est demander à
tous ce que j'ai à vous dire tout
simplement c'est est-ce que vous n'êtes
pas fatigué par cette stratégie ridicule
et je dois le dire un peu misérable dont
vous avez usé pendant un an qui n'a
toujours pas porté ses
fruits votre irresponsabilité a des
conséquences peut-être en prenez-vous
conscience désormais en tout cas je
l'espère et peut-être que ce temps qui
est venu est douloureux au-delà du fait
qu'elle vous discrédite auprès de nos
compatriotes elle ne fait que diviser
les Français toujours un peu plus dans
un contexte national et
internationalement
complexe notre assemblée est plurielle
et diverse elle est représentative du
vote des Français à un instanté soyons
riches de cette
diversité un an après si l'on considère
que c'est le temps qu'il vous aura fallu
pour que vous preniez vos marques il est
attendu que vous soyez
constructif stop aux agitations
caricaturales stop aux postures de cours
d'école stop au fait de pousser aussi
loin qu'il soit possible la
conflictualité à vouloir casser les
codes de la politique vous êtes tombé
dans des travers desquels vous n'arriz
plus à sortir de la surenchè du toujours
plus du toujours pire avec pour seul
objectif de créer de l'instabilité de la
colère et de la division cela n'a mené à
rien à rien si ce n'est que de faire de
le jeu que de l'autre partie de
l'hémicycle certains d'entre vous l'ont
compris et d'autres n'ont plus envie
d'être associé à vous l'outrance est une
voie de garage l'attente est ailleurs il
est urgent désormais de changer
d'approche le pays a besoin d'un projet
de loi des finances de la sécurité
sociale
il passera par le
493 puisqu'il n'est pas possible qu'il
en soit
autrement l'année
dernière je vous posais ici même une
question à quoi sert votre motion de
censure je vous
demandais avec cette motion avez-vous
vraiment l'espoir de renverser le
gouvernement en coalisant toutes les
oppositions contre lui la réponse est la
même non avez-vous l'espoir de une
majorité alternative en joignant aux
voix de la nuupesse celle des
républicains et de l'extrême droite la
réponse est la même non avez-vous
l'espoir de modifier l'orientation du
PLFSS dans un sens qui serait plus
favorable à votre ligne politique la
réponse est toujours la même non nous
sommes tous ici un an après et votre
motion de censure n'est rien d'autre que
c'est qu'elle était déjà une motion d'or
un conseil asseyez-vous dessus et
envisagez de construire il est grand
temps je vous remercie je vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Nicolas dupontignant en sa qualité de
député non inscrit pour une durée de 5
minutes madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre messieurs les
ministres et madames les ministres
Bertle brcht en son temps écrivait avec
ironie le peuple a perdu la confiance du
gouvernement et ce n'est qu'en
redoublant d'effort qu'il peut la
regagner ne serait-il pas plus simple
alors pour le gouvernement de dissoudre
le peuple et d'en élire un autre cette
célèbre phrase résume parfaitement votre
conception autocratique de notre
démocratie mercredi 25 octobre à cette
même tribune avec une incroyable langue
de bois vous avez osé mentir droit dans
les yeux madame la Première ministre à
la représentation nationale mensonge car
contrairement à ce que vous avez dit
vous n'avez jamais vraiment recherché
des points d'accord avec les oppositions
mais seulement avec votre
minorité mensonge car vous avez anticipé
le rejet de votre budget sans comme le
faisaient vos prédécesseur avant de
déclencher leur 493 laisser le temps aux
députés de débattre et d'examiner les
amendement pour la 14e fois avec un air
radieux vous avez été fier d'empêcher
l'Assemblée nationale de jouer son rôle
de législateur et fier de bafouer la
volonté populaire car oui aux élections
législatives les Français se sont
exprimés et ont refusé de vous donner
une majorité comme à Emmanuel car il ne
voulait pas le voir appliquer son
programme vous n'avez jamais accepté le
résultat des élection législative ne
vous en déplaise les députés
représentants du peuple sont ici par la
volonté des Français tandis que vous
Premier ministre vous n'êtes ici que par
la volonté d'un seul
homme il y a un conflit de légitimité
démocratique entre président de la
République d'un côté et l'Assemblée
nationale de l'autre élu à 2 mois
d'intervalle croyez-vous d'ailleurs
sincèrement que vous allez pouvoir
encore pendant 3 ans et demi additionner
multiplier les 493 sans que les Français
soient de plus en plus nombreux à en
être scandalisés au risque d'alimenter
le discrédit total de nos institutions
républicaines vous sieiez la branche sur
laquelle vous êtes assis c'est c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs le général de Gaulle
avait prévu le référendum ou la
dissolution en cas de crise pour donner
aux Français le pouvoir d'arbitrage
ultime n'oublions jamais l'article 2 de
notre Constitution que vous piétinez
allaigrement le principe de la
République est le gouvernement du peuple
par le peuple et pour le peuple et si
vous êtes si sûr de votre loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
pourquoi sur votre politique sociale
n'osez-vous pas le référendum mais vous
n'en voulez jamais ni sur l'immigration
ni sur les retraites ni sur l'Union
européenne vous ne respectez pas le
peuple car vous ne n'aimez pas le peuple
vous ne respectez pas davantage les
corps intermédiaires votre projet de loi
a d'ailleurs été rejeté par tous le
conseil de la Caisse nationale de
l'assurance maladie les fédérations
hospitalières la Fédération nationale
des infirmiers les syndicats les casaes
àocation familiales et pour la première
fois dans l'histoire par les oppositions
en commission l'ensemble du pays vous
exprime avec bon sens son refus de cette
loi de financement et vous avez
l'inconscience l'arrogance le mépris de
vouloir toujours passer en force comme
si de rien n'était avec ce projet de loi
rien n'est fait pour redonner une
bouffée d'oxygène à notre système de
santé et stopper sa
déliqueessence madame qui s'est exprimé
avant moi a oublié tout simplement
l'inflation rien sur les déserts
médicaux rien de sérieux sur la pénurie
de soignau et de médicaments rien de
sérieux sur les fermetures d'hôpitaux et
de services d'urgence la nuit rien de
sérieux sur la politique familiale rien
de sérieux sur l'indispensable chasse au
gaspillage pour garantir le financement
de soins de qualité partout sur notre
territoire mes chers collègues il est
plus qu'urgent de censurer ce
gouvernement pour l'empêcher de faire du
mal aux Français il est urgent finir
avec cette mascarade parlementaire les
Français nous regardent et seront
distingués ceux qui sont cohérent dans
leur vote dans leur choix de ceux qui
n'ont d'opposition que leur nom et qui
sont en fait votre roue de secours pour
ma part vous ne m'aurez pas à l'usure et
je voterai 493 après 493 comme toujours
la censure car je suis convaincu que
c'est l'intérêt supérieur du
pays
[Musique]
merci tous les orateurs inscrits se sont
exprimés la parole est à madame la
Première
[Applaudissements]
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés nous nous retrouvons à nous
nouveau et cet examen de deux motions de
censure ressemble à tous les autres
beaucoup d'outrance beaucoup de posture
beaucoup de contrevérités et à la fin
l'extrême droite et l'extrême gauche qui
vote
ensemble alors Monsieur l'orateur du
rassemblement national vous pouvez
prétendre condamner les positions de la
France insoumise mais motion après
motion vous votez
ensemble mesdames et messieurs les
députés pourtant avec mon gouvernement
avec la majorité je ne m'habitue pas je
ne'habitue pas au mensonge de ceux qui
qui se procl les défenseurs de notre
modèle social et veulent censurer 640
milliards d'euros d'investissement c'est
30 milliards d'euros de plus que cette
année c'est trois fois plus que le
chèque de 10 milliards brandi par la
France insoumise je ne m'habitue pas aux
impostures de ceux qui se proclament les
défenseurs de notre hôpital et de la
santé des Français et se sont pourtant
coalisés pour rejeter une augmentation
de 2,8 milliards d'euros de longam pour
2023 augmentation que vous dites
pourtant appelé de vos vœux monsieur le
député
Gedge je ne m'habitue pas au hurlement
de ceux qui se procl les défenseurs du
débat parlementaire mais le dénature à
coup d'invective et de tentative
d'obstruction je ne m'habitue pas à la
mauvaise foi de ceux qui créent au
passage en force mais refuseent toute
recherche de
compromis je ne m'habitue pas mais plus
encore je refuse de m'habituer les excès
et la surenchère constante les faits
tronqués et les réalités déformées mine
la confiance de nos concitoyens dans nos
institutions ça n'est pas ma conception
de la politique ça n'est pas celle de
mon gouvernement ça n'est pas celle de
la
[Applaudissements]
majorité
nous resterons toujours les partisans du
dialogue et de la recherche de compromis
ce projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale n'y fait pas exception
les ministres ont échangé avec les
représentants de tous les groupes
parlementaires et nous avons retenu des
amendements de la majorité comme des
oppositions nous resterons toujours
déterminés à apporter des solutions et
des résultats aux Français alors je
n'ignore rien de la spécificité des
textes budgétaires marqueur de
l'appartenance à une majorité qui
conduit les oppositions à ne pas les
voter quel que soit le contenu et quelle
mauvaise fois monsieur le député péavi
de faire semblant de l'ignorer de notre
côté notre devoir c'est l'action nous ne
pouvions pas prendre le moindre risque
car ce serait privé notre sécurité
sociale de ces moyens nous le pouvions
d'autant moins qu'il n'existe sur ces
bancs aucune majorité alternative
capable de s'accorder sur un
aussi comme je l'ai toujours fait et
comme je le ferai toujours j'agis dans
l'intérêt du pays et je prends mes
responsabilité mesdames et messieurs les
députés notre modèle social doit être
protégé et c'est pour le défendre que
j'ai engagé la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement grâce à cette deè partie du
PLFSS nous marquons une nouvelle ha
moyen de la sécurité sociale tout en
garantissant la soutenabilité financière
de notre modèle une nouvelle Haus des
moyens consacré à la santé entre 2017 et
2024 l'ONDAM aura augmenté de 65
milliards d'euros c'est plus de 33 % de
hausse c'est sans
[Applaudissements]
précédent et les moyens dégagés par
cette deè partie du PLFSS ils vont
mettre les revalorisations des salaires
des soignants et des mesures
d'attractivité pour l'hôpital ils vont
permettre d'amplifier notre politique de
prévention essentielle pour la santé de
nos concitoyens ils vont permettre de
financer notre objectif de 50000 postes
supplémentaires dans les éepades d'ici
2030 dont 6000 dès l'année prochaine je
vous le confirme monsieur le député
Lenormand de garantir des solutions
d'accueil pour les enants de revaloriser
les prestations familiales et les
pensions ils vont permettre de déployer
dès 2024 7000 nouvelles solutions
d'accompagnement pour les personnes en
situation de handicap alors je le
demande à l'extrême droite comme à
l'extrême gauche comment pouvez-vous
prétendre que c'est un budget
d'austérité car cette deuxième partie du
PLFSS avec cette deuxème partie nous
renforçons encore nos actions de lutte
contre la fraude sociale c'est une lutte
que nous menons avec détermination car
frauder c'est voler la République et
priver ceux qui en ont le plus
[Applaudissements]
besoin grâce à cette deuxième partie du
PLFSS nous tenons les engagements que
nous avons pris lors de la réforme des
retraites ne pas opérer de transfert du
recouvrement des cotisations de retraite
complémentaires vers les URSAF garantir
le financement des pensions de tous les
affiliés des régimes spéciaux que nous
avons fermés malgré l'absence de
nouveaux cotisants respecter le dialogue
social déterminant pour avancer sur des
préoccupations majeures des français
grâce à cette deuxème partie du PLFSS
nous améliorons la régulation économique
des produits de santé et grâce aux
amendements de la majorité comme des
oppositions nous avons pu enrichir ce
texte je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer ici
le travail mené par la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
Charlotte parmenontier Lecoq et par la
rapporteur générale Stéphanie R
[Applaudissements]
ces amendements vont rendre plus
efficaces encore nos dispositifs de
lutte contre la fraude ils vont
sécuriser le niveau des contributions
pharmaceutiques pour les industriels ils
vont permettre des avancé pour les
agriculteurs ou pour les lycéens de la
voie professionnelle ils vont permettre
de sécuriser les recettes de la sécurité
sociale en 2024 en limitant
l'augmentation du coût des allègements
de
cotisation c'est grâce au travail avec
les organisations professionnelles que
la deuxème partie du PLFSS a été
enrichie d'une mesure très attendue par
les travailleurs indépendants grâce à
cette réforme les artisans les
commerçants et les professions libérales
amélioreront leur retraite après
lèvement social inchangé c'est une
mesure de justice que les indépendants
attendaient depuis longtemps grâce à ce
PLFSS nous la mettons en
œuvre enfin j'ajoute que par ces
amendements comme par ceux que nous
avons décidé de ne pas déposer nous
montrons notre confiance dans le
dialogue social certains d'entre vous à
commencé par votre Président Monsieur le
Député nuder m'ont interrogé sur la
situation d'agir Arco mon objectif a
toujours été de garantir que la réforme
des retraites produise tous ses effets
il en va de notre responsabilité
collective pour y parvenir je crois au
dialogue social je préfère laisser les
partenaires sociaux trouver des
solutions plutôt que de contraindre les
ressources de l'agir Carco dans leur
accord les partenaires sociaux ont
eux-mêmes ouvert la porte pour financer
dispositif de solidarité à la lumière
des déclarations de la semaine dernière
je leur fais confiance pour qu'ils
trouvent un accord assurant une
solidarité financière entre régimes au
profit des pensions des plus
modestes
mesdames et messieurs les députés la
sécurité sociale c'est notre histoire et
notre bien commun c'est la solidarité et
la promesse d'égalité républicaine en
acte alors sur ce texte plus encore que
sur d'autres nous devrions être CAPA de
nous retrouver capable de débattre de
bonne foi et de chercher ensemble les
meilleures solutions pour nos
concitoyens sur ce texte comme sur tous
les budgets nous avons le devoir
d'avancer et de prendre nos
responsabilités ce texte est nécessaire
pour le versement des prestations
familiales et des retraites pour le
financement de nos hôpitaux et la
rémunération de nos soignants je ne
renoncerai ni au dialogue ni ni à
l'action et je suis fier de défendre ce
texte qui renforce encore notre modèle
social je vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie
merci madame la Première
ministre la discussion commune est close
je vais maintenant mettre au voix la
motion de censure déposé par Madame pano
madame Chatelin monsieur chassegne et
111 membres de l'Assemblée le scrutin
est annoncé dans l'enceinte de
l'Assemblée nationale je rappelle que
seul les députés favorables à la motion
de censure participent au scrutin et que
le vote se déroule dans les salles
voisines de l'hémicycle le scrutin va
être ouvert pour 20 minutes il sera donc
clos à 17h20 la séance est
suspendue
voici le résultat du scrutin majorité
requise pour l'adoption de la motion de
censure soit la majorité absolue des
membres composant l'Assemblée nationale
de 189 pour l'adoption 223 la majorité
requise n'étant pas atteinte la motion
de censure n'est pas adopté je vais
maintenant mettre au voix la motion de
censure déposée par Madame Le Pen et 87
membres de l'Assemblée le scrutin est
annoncé dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée
nationale je rappelle à nouveau que seul
les députés favorables à la motion de
censure participe au scrutin et que le
vote se déroule dans les salles voisines
de l'hémicycle le scrutin va être ouvert
pour une durée de 20 minutes il sera
donc clos à
17h43 la séance est
suspendue la séance est reprise voici le
résultat du scrutin majorité requise
pour l'adoption de la motion de censure
soit la majorité absolue des membres
composant l'assemblée 289 pour
l'adoption 88 la majorité requise
n'étant pas à la motion de censure n'est
pas adoptée aucune des deux motions
déposées n'ayant été adopté la deuxième
partie du projet loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour 2024 est
considérée comme
adopté je vous remercie je vais
suspendre la séance quelques minutes
avant de reprendre l'ordre du
jour